alo alo. Xin chào tất cả bạn. Alo.
hôm qua. Ờ
qua làm quả ảnh thăm.
Ừ
Gemini để tạo ra ảnh thăm nhưng mà
đại khái nó nặng.
Dùng cái gì để tạo ảnh thăm bây giờ độ
giá thấp hơn, nhẹ hơn nhỉ?
Ờ hỏi chat GPT đi.
Đây
lại tôi phải tạm bể như này cho nó bớt
nhạy cảm. Che bớt nhạy cảm đã. Ờ
nén ảnh
để giung lượng
online
phí ở đấy. Đấy xin chào các bạn.
Thực ra cũng đang không đang hiển thị là
bốn người xem đồng thời
đang không biết được là có ai đang xem
không. Nhưng không quan trọng. Thường là
à không phải nói các bạn không quan
trọng mà ý là kiểu gọi như nào nhỉ? Là
mình biết đa số những người xem của
mình.
thường không có thời gian để xem trực
tiếp và xem lại là xem lại hoặc là nói
chung xem sau ấy khá là lớn nên là tôi
đang quay những cái này cho dù kể cả
chưa có ai cả thì tôi vẫn sẽ phải nói
bởi vì tôi biết được là
à đôi khi ở chế giản chính bản thân mình
về sau xem lại thôi cũng được cũng biết
được tôi vẫn thỉnh thoảng hồi trước vẫn
thỉnh thoảng có ngồi xem lại những cái
video mình đương nhiên là tua thôi chứ
không thể tua theo kiểu là x2 ấy. Ừ. Đấy
là một trong những cái cách hay bởi vì
nhiều người bảo là xem của anh nói khá
là chậm nhưng mà x2 lên nó lại nhanh, nó
lại hợp lý kiểu kiểu ừ mình lại cảm thấy
có tí giống như kiểu hack thời gian. À
đấy kiểu thế.
Tiny image. Ok. Thử xem.
utm x thực ra mấy cái ui bây giờ kiểu
dùng vai code nhiều làm giao diện nhiều
ấ nhìn cái này cũng giống như vai code
ra ấy. Trông giống thật giống thật ý.
Xem nào.
Đây web đi nhìn giống cực.
không? Hôm qua đã cố nén lại một tí rồi.
Nhưng mà thực ra nó chả nghĩa gì. Hai
thằng giống hệt nhau.
Nén
7 m. Nén lại,
nén lại cũng là tầm
3 m nhưng mà
xem
đây thử cái này xem.
nặng hơn á. Ông bịp tôi à?
Xong rồi sao?
Now what? À xong rồi lựa chọn đây.
Đấy xong rồi
Nên thôi không sao m cũng được.
ngần này mê đâu. Nhầm rồi.
Nó bảo là à nó dự kiến ở đây. Ok. Th cử
web như này đi cho chắc đi.
vẻ hơi khó dùng.
Ơ vừa rồi mình ấn hai rồi không mình
chọn một thôi.
Xin chào bạn
xin chào các bạn. Các bạn cứ bình luận
tôi vẫn để ý nhá.
Smart gì đó đây. Thở giải thử nén.
Ok. Uây kinh phết nhỉ. Đang từ 70 m
trông như này mà
các thứ thứ xịn nhỉ.
Nút tải của tôi đâu? À đây này
Ờ
ảnh thăm. Để tôi a
thay cho cái sau. À cái cũ và cái sau
vậy
cũng ổn mà đúng không? Cái này tôi dùng
Gemini ấy. Gemini tạo ra ảnh ấy. Đó là
tôi bảo là livestream YouTube. Cái này
không phải tôi đâu nhá. Mấy không thấy
mà đúng không? Cái này không phải tôi.
Tôi bảo livestream YouTube để học 100
ngày học Java đấy, xong rồi vân vân vân
cái gì gì đó. Ui ngày một mà như này
đấy.
Dũng Huyền ở đây ai tôi không biết.
Nhưng mà nói chung là tôi cũng muốn hay
cái ảnh kia vì cái ảnh kia tôi lấy trên
mạng về không biết có bị dính bản quyền
gì không đấy. Nhưng mà mình nên né đúng
không?
mấy cái này.
Tôi sẽ
Còn
còn bài hiện tại thì có vẻ là đang
nhỉ?
Ơ thay được ảnh thăm bài hiện tại này
ngon.
Ơ nhưng mà nó vẫn còn chữ ngày một.
để tôi thử dùng JD bảo tạo hai xem như
nào. Đợi đợi tôi một tí nhá. đang hơi
rảnh một tí.
cho tôi ảnh ngày hai đấy.
Xem nhờ hay là nó chỉ thay đổi mỗi cái
chữ ngày hai là nó sẽ thay đổi cả những
cái khác nữa. Tôi thì đang mong chờ là
nó sẽ thay đổi một tí cái khác nữa nhưng
vẫn giữ nguyên cái tông đấy.
Ngồm lắm là đoạn code ở trên này thay
đổi này chẳng hạn. Thế đúng không ạ?
kiểu German
AI Pro à. Đấy nên là tôi sẽ phải dùng
triệt để nó. hôm nay cũng ngồi bình luận
ở trên J2 Team Community bảo là nghĩa là
hôm nay Apple công bố là sẽ tích hợp
Germany vào thay thế cho Apple
Intelligent nghĩa là AI của Apple không
được tốt ấy nên là thôi dùng luôn của
Gemini làm trợ ý ảo đấy tôi thì tôi thì
bảo là Gemini có tốt nhưng mà Gemini
cũng có tốt đâu. Đấy thì mọi người cũng
có ném đá.
Tôi thì thực ra tôi chưa dùng Gemini à.
Tôi có dùng Gemini nhưng mà trên Android
để làm trợ ý ảo thì tôi thấy nó rất là
củùi. Thậm chí là chat dùng ứng dụng
chat cũng rất là cùi nên là tôi a không
thích nó lắm.
Ơ thật này, nó chỉ thay mỗi ngày hai cả
số hai này. Có tất cả còn giữ nguyên ạ.
Ok.
Thôi cũng được.
nhờ bắt bắt nó ngồi làm tiếp cũng được
cho trùng một tông.
nhờ ai làm này
tí
à. đổi
cho tôi màn hình code và phần bình luận.
Còn đâu giữ nguyên
những cái khác
thử nhá.
Nghịch tí.
ait hôm qua của tôi có cập tôi mới cập
nhật đấy thì tôi có cập nhật à
bổ sung thêm ví dụ hôm qua đã kiểu anh
em mình đã chốt là thêm được vài cái mới
thực ra mình còn chưa học đến đúng không
nhưng mà hôm nay có bạn nói với tôi, bạn
ấy cũng kiểu kỳ cứ cho là tôi cảm thấy
là rất là xịn rồi, cũng chắc cũng phải
là senior rồi. Bạn ấy tư vấn cho tôi về
à
tool chọn banana nó hơi nó gen ảnh xịn
hơn ha.
không không để ý được để là để khác
code này hay gì? Bài tập hôm nay hay quá
cố lên. Ok tiếp nào. Xin ch
ơ nhưng mà thy vẫn giữ nguyên được. Cái
này cũng đỉnh đấy. Bởi vì thằng chatt
hồi trước nó không giữ được cái kiểu
tông như này đâu. Được đấy. Cũng giữ
được các thứ thứ. Thay ngày hai này. Màn
hình khác này. Màn hình lần này Java
hiển thị rõ chữ thêm code mới ở đây này.
Màn hình code hồi trước thì trông xịn
hơn, ngầu hơn. Màn hình này trông kiểu
thôi cũng được. Dai. Ok cũng được.
À quên phải nén nó lại đã.
À xem nào.
Thêm rồi. Ok. Nén gì đó vẫn là 7 m
kiểu giao diện đúng kiểu giao diện ai
làm hay gì đó sao
trông không dễ dùng lắm. Tôi cảm thấy
thế đấy. Đợi tí thay ảnh mới.
Ok.
tham mới trống xịn phết nhỉ. Được. Bây
giờ mỗi ngày tôi sẽ vào tôi cập nhật
thêm.
Ok. Rồi thì hôm qua à chính xác hôm nay
bạn đấy mới bảo tôi bổ sung thêm cái
khái niệm là mental
men mentor
cái gì? Tôi không biết phát âm cái từ
này chuẩn mental mà đúng không?
Go dịch nào?
Translate
>> Mental đúng rồi. Mental
mental
model đấy nhưo, Java. Đấy. Thay vì kiểu
hôm mấy hôm trước là mình sẽ học kiểu
map 11 từ PP sang, tức là PP có cái gì
thì mình sẽ map sang và mình sẽ so sánh
sự khác biệt. Còn cái này thì nó sẽ liên
quan đến tư duy cất lõi này. Đấy, đọc
trước khi học. Uầi. Đấy, anh em mình sẽ
ngồi à đọc qua một trước một chút được
không ạ? Đấy, dùng màn hình này cho dễ
nhìn nhá.
PP. Đấy, đầu tiên thì PP đấy. Kiểu hôm
đề cập cái này khá là hay vì tôi không
biết cái này thật. Tôi có thể mấy ông
biết nhưng tôi không biết thật. Đây ví
dụ là một request thì khởi động lại thì
cái này thì anh em PP biết này. Nhưng mà
cái này còn sống lâu này. Duy trì các
nghĩa nó vẫn chạy tiếp được. Đấy, cái
này tôi không phải biết kiểu memory tự
giải phóng xong mỗi request. Đấy, tôi
nghĩ là đây là một trong những cái lý do
mà bọn tôi không quan tâm đến cái
memory, không quan tâm đến quản lý cái
bộ nhớ. Đấy, bởi vì rõ ràng là sau
request là nó sẽ được xóa sạch kiểu thậm
chí là sau mỗi method. Tôi nhớ tôi nhớ
là thế.
Để tí hỏi lại xem. Hỏ lại luôn nhỉ.
Ừ, hỏi lại luôn.
À nhưng mà trong này à trong này không
tôi nghĩ là tôi hỏi ở trong chatt này
đi. À
sau
mỗi request
bộ nhớ.
À đâu chắc là bỏ cái này đi sau mỗi
đúng không? Đây
dần trong quá trình chạy
biến cục bộ
không còn tham chiếu nhưng thu hồi thực
sự reference
rabit collector.
Nếu con reference return ra ngoài gắn
vào property
method đấy khai báo trong method đấy và
kết thúc metus thì tôi nghĩ vẫn sẽ giải
phóng
không chạy sau mỗi method nghĩa là nó
vẫn còn ở đấy nhưng mà cái này khi nó sẽ
tự động chạy sau kiểu đạt cái ngưỡng ở
đó thì chạy. Ok.
Property object này.
Closer này. Global scope này. CCL
reference này.
Long run process này. Đấy. Ok.
này tôi chưa dùng. Microservice thì thực
ra là có kiểu đang tôi còn đang không rõ
là công ty có đang chơi theo kiểu dùng
microservice hay không.
lớn dài trong lúp dài tránh giữ
reference chia nhỏ.
circle
phết hay phết. À có nhắc đến Java này à
chắc là nó nhớ tôi đang học Java. Ok.
Không quan tâm th đúng không? Còn không
biết th nó tồn tại ở trong PP luôn ấy.
Đấy. À đấy là tôi vẫn đang nói là cái
trình độ tôi nhá. Ôi tôi bắt đầu
suy nghĩ lại khái niệm mình có chắc là
sino không hay mình chỉ là làm lâu
ứng dụng
Java hệ thống dài hạn đây không phải
second nghĩa là thường là người ta vẫn
khuyên là làm một cái web nào nhanh thì
mình sẽ dùng PP
còn à trong trường hợp mà mình gọi là
mình à
Java đúng không? Thì làm một cái hệ
thống làm một cái gì đó kiểu cần cần
phải maintain tên, cần phải duy trì lâu
dài. Đấy nó không phải làm mỗi cái kiểu
làm nhanh gọi là hơi ăn sổi một tí đúng
không? PP thậm chí là Gopet chẳng hạn.
Đây
cùng một class nó vẫn chạy được. Đấy
kiểu thế nó khác với kiểu bên này đại
diện với các thứ thứ gì đó phải op phải
hướng đối tượng phải các thứ phải kiểu
giảng buộc hơn.
inmobility
chắc là vẫn phải thế là làm dần mới
hiểu.
Content này hay nhé anh. Thực ra tôi
phục vụ cá nhân tôi là chủ yếu chứ không
phải mấy ông. Bởi vì rõ ràng là tôi a
tôi có tham khảo mấy ông đâu. Tôi à
không phải dùng từ không tham khảo mà
tôi không hỏi ý kiến mấy ông. Tôi vẫn
làm mấy cái này
sẽ có người thấy phù hợp, có người thấy
là
họ biết rồi chẳng hạn hoặc đơn giản là
họ chưa đến
họ chưa đến cái giai đoạn mà cần phải
biết một cái này. Đấy rất nhiều cái nên
thành ra là tôi chỉ chia sẻ lại vì vẫn
luôn là theo cái phương hướng là mình
chia sẻ và ai thấy có ích thì thì tốt
cho họ thôi. Còn mình thì mình thích
chia sẻ thì mình cứ chia sẻ
PP mãi
mute là bất biến à.
Ok để xem để xem
cái này nhiều từ tiếng Anh chuyên ngày
phết đấy.
executor này. Uầy uầy thựt ra tôi nghĩ
là đọc cái đống này xong quá tải không
ạ?
Thôi cứ từ từ từ đã nhé. Tôi nghĩ sẽ từ
từ. Hôm trước làm cái buổi một, hôm qua
ôn buổi một. Ok này. Hôm nay nhắc lại
buổi hai một tí nhá.
Hôm nay là buổi ba nhưng mà ừ nhỉ? Hôm
nay chuẩn là buổi ba. Đấy. Cái tiêu đề
của cái video ghi là buổi thứ hai. Nhưng
thực ra hôm nay hôm trước tôi đã học một
buổi offline rồi.
rồi mình sẽ sang buổi ba nhá. Thì hôm
qua tôi nhớ quả string bull này rồi đấy.
Lúc đầu như lúc đầu tôi nói tôi còn nhầm
tưởng cái ba chấm này nó tạo cho một cái
kiểu gì đó
là để mà ghi lại những cái công việc mà
tôi sẽ làm thì tôi dùng cái Microsoft
Todo. Tôi có biết cái
notion nhưng mà tôi không dùng nó cũng
như là dùng cái
dùng cái gì nhỉ? dùng Google Keep thì
thực ra nó lại kiểu tôi không ghi chú
nhiều tôi thường là chỉ ghi lại các ý
tưởng và các và tôi co nó các đầu việc
đấy gọi các tas đúng không to do list
đấy thì tôi tùng dùng cái Microsoft to
do này này đây đấy của tôi có rất nhiều
đầu việc tôi đi sẽ mở cho mấy ông xem
như là tôi sợ là có gì nhạy cảm nên là à
đây đấy kiểu như này mấy ông sẽ thấy
Trong hôm nay tôi đã cố làm xong hết
rồi.
Đây các đầu việc này. Xong rồi. Đây
những công việc trên công ty này. Cái
này dự án này đấy khi quay dậy này.
Notốt lại những cái mà mình sẽ quay dậy
các thứ. Đấy đi du lịch thì sẽ cần những
cái gì? Ý tưởng này, mua sắm này. Đây
cũng là mấy cái mẹo về dạy này, khám
này,
à học này học à đây mình tích việc của
mình đang học Java nữa xong còn ý định
đi chung này. Đấy, đây là viết tắt của
tên bạn gái.
À cái này là mình cái tiện ích gần đây
tôi có làm thì tôi kiểu đánh dấu lại
kiểu có ý tưởng gì cho nó hoặc là đây có
ai báo bức gì thì mình sẽ nốt lại. Đây
nó to đ mà. Đấy làm á ma sói. Á ma sói
này hình như là mình mới chỉ tạo repo
mình cũng chưa làm gì. Bắt tay làm. Nói
chung là có rất nhiều ý tưởng để vi code
nhưng mà chưa làm cả cái
ứng dụng này nữa. Cái ứng dụng này là
cái quả là đồng bộ trên các mọi nền tảng
nhưng cái đấy sẽ đang ý tưởng thứ ý
tưởng từ lâu rồi nhưng mà vẫn chưa thời
gian. Và đây cái này nữa là cái trang
web cho cá nhân. Nghĩa là
ô để tôi vào lại cái trang của chính
mình đã sợ quên. Đúng rồi
đấy. Trang web chtimnl.com của tôi.
Nhưng mà bây giờ biến thành cái trang tỏ
tình. Mấy ông có có gì mấy ông đừng vào
nhá. Nhưng đại khái thì hồi trưa tôi có
tôi sẽ ngồi sửa lại cái trang này để
nó thành một cái trang giống
portfolio à
không nhớ cách phát âm chuẩn từ đấy lắm
xem
Portfolio
đấy đúng nhỉ? Viết đúng nhỉ?
Đúng rồi. Portio
đấy. Nghĩa đại khái thì bình thường mấy
không biết về khái niệm CV rồi nhưng mà
CV mình sẽ viết ngắn gọn ở trên trang
đấy. Thường là chỉ là một trang thôi
nhưng mà rõ ràng là một cái trang cá
nhân của ông thì ông hoàn toàn có thể
kiểu liệt kê ra hết toàn bộ cái những
cái dự án ông từng làm xong rồi giới
thiệu bản thân. vân vân tù thứ đấy thì
nó sẽ khái niệm
port portfolio gì đấy. Đấy thì tôi sẽ
sửa lại cái trang web cho chính mình.
Bởi vì hôm trước tôi bảo tôi dùng AI để
mà ngồi ném đá CV của tôi ấ thì nó cũng
đề cập về vụ đấy. Nghĩa là mang tiếng
kêu là mày lập trình viên web mà mày lại
tải CV từ top CV à. Đấy kiểu mày đáng lẽ
phải có một trang riêng đấy vân vân. Đấy
phải có một CV riêng gì đó. Đại khái
thế.
Ờ thanh niên xài hệ Apple chơi hàng
Microsoft.
Đúng. Thực ra là tôi muốn a thực ra là
tôi muốn là kiểu dùng chung hết vào một
cái thôi. Ví dụ giả sử là tôi chính ra
tôi không thích Microsoft hoàn toàn tôi
thích Google nhất. Nhưng mà bây giờ để
mà kiểu mình tự add bản thân mình dùng
mấy cái kiểu như là bây giờ là phải dùng
hồi trước Google có
laptop là Chromebook này. Đấy dùng
Chromebook
đã thấy là cẩu tự mình vào một cái hệ
sinh thái rồi kín rồi đấy. Xong rồi. À
nói chung là tôi cảm thấy là mình là dân
công nghệ mình nên trải nghiệm đồ không
hẳn là trải nghiệm theo kiểu là
kiểu tôi vẫn sợ cái kiểu FOMo à
Là tôi biết từ đấy dịch tiếng Việt nhưng
mà để nói văn văn vở là như nào nhỉ? Nói
chung là tôi không chạy theo xu hướng
đấy. Tôi không chạy theo xu hướng nhưng
mà tôi vẫn cảm thấy là cái gì mà tôi
thấy tôi sẽ dùng thử đúng không? Cái gì
mà cảm thấy nó phù hợp với cái nhu cầu
của mình thì mình dùng. Đấy,
các thứ thế thì tự nhiên mình bị cuốn
theo ấy. Và và lúc đấy mình lại không có
cái
ý kiến chính kiến riêng của bản thân
mình là thực sự là nó đủ tốt mà mình chỉ
nghe cái khác nói tốt thì thôi mình
dùng. Đấy, mình phải thực sự là mình
dùng qua một cái này xong mình chuyển
qua khác. Có lý do. Ví dụ giả sử nhá, có
bạn vừa nhắc là tôi hồi trước tôi dùng
Win chẳng hạn. Thực ra tôi vẫn có máy
dùng Win ở đây bởi vì đi dậy thực ra là
các bạn vẫn phải dùng máy win bởi đôi
khi là kết nối máy vân vân nhiều cái
hoặc chỉ đơn giản là các bạn thao tác
mọi thứ thì kiểu gọi nh học sinh sinh
viên mình có thể nhìn được mình thao tác
và có thể bắt trước làm ở trên máy nhà
trường hay gì gì đó
nên lượng người dùng Win bây giờ đông mà
nên là mình sẽ phải kiểu làm mẫu cho học
sinh là nhiều đấy nên vẫn phải dùng win.
Vẫn có những phần mềm chỉ cài được trên
Win đấy nhưng mà bây giờ là tôi cùng
code thì máy này chuyên để code hay các
thứ thì rõ ràng là tôi và tôi bây giờ
không chơi game mấy nữa nên thành ra là
tôi dùng M vẫn được
nhưng mà mình vẫn sẽ có nhiều hàng thô
chẳng phải của Apple. Thực ra Apple thì
chắc là về phần cứng hơn. Về phần mềm
thì tôi vẫn thấy không được phá lắm
nên là vẫn không dùng.
Ok. Đấy thì tôi dùng cái app Microsoft
Tod. Nó có cả trên mọi hệ điều hành. Các
bạn vừa thấy là nó có ở trên M đúng
không ạ? Vẫn dùng được, vẫn ngon.
Ok. À
đúng. Sợ nhất là cái phần mà kiểu mỗi
nơi 1 tỷ ấ xong rồi mình sẽ phải đồng bộ
sang đúng không? Đấy do tôi dùng
Microsoft Tod vì nó là nó có trên mọi
mọi cái từ trên máy tính này từ trên
điện thoại này, trên cả hệ sinh thái
khác này. Chắc là Linus thì nó chưa có
thôi nhưng mà tôi không dùng Linus đấy.
RAM cao chắc quá.
Thực ra thì
ma nó đang có một cái rất là hay
nhưng mà tôi vẫn đang cố kiểu lên con
cao nhất đấy. Nhưng mà thực sự thì ma có
cái rất là hay. Nó khác với win ở một
chỗ đó là
là bình thường là win mà ra 18 thậm chí
8 đúng không? Rồi xác định kiểu chỉ chạy
được mấy cái cơ bản đúng không? Nhưng mà
Mar thì ngoài việc tối ưu gì đó như bọn
nó hay nói. Đấy cái đấy tôi không biết.
Tôi không phải chuyên gia để mà th để mà
ngồi so sánh hay là ngồi mở cái gì đó
lên để đo. Nhưng mà tôi sẽ cảm nhận được
là 16 GB RAM của M kết hợp với việc là
nó còn chạy khái niệm là nó chạy chèn
sang cái nó là cái chạy chèn sang cái
swap này này. Đấy nghĩa là ông dùng
memory ở đây rồi đúng không?
Đấy, đây là gig RAM của ông này. Ông
dùng memory bình thường ông dùng ở đây
xong rồi nó còn nhảy qua scrap là nó sẽ
dùng vào trong bộ đĩa của ông ấy. Đương
nhiên là nó không nhanh bằng RAM nhưng
mà nó vẫn kiểu nếu mà ông thiếu quá nó
vẫn nhảy vào đây thì nghĩa là ông vẫn mở
được, vẫn mở được các phần mềm các thứ
chẳng qua nó có thể chậm hơn. Xỉ gì
không? Nghĩa là rõ ràng là thực tế là 16
GB của M là tương đối hơn so với 16 của
Win rồi đấy. 16 của Win mở thêm cái là
treo luôn đúng không ạ? Còn ma thì không
treo. Đấy được
ok. Thôi nó hơi ra dòng tí. Nói chung là
mấy ông cứ bình luận thì tôi vẫn tôi vẫn
đọc và tôi vẫn trả lời nhá. Có gì tôi
lại ngồi học tiếp thôi.
Đấy, dùng cái nháy kép này để mà để biến
nó là cũng khai báo nó string nhưng kèm
theo là sẽ đẩy vào string pool đúng
không ạ?
Uầy mấy cái này mấy cái từ khóa này về
sau chắc là chắc là đi phỏng vấn người
ta không hỏi mấy cái lý thuyết này đâu.
Đấy nhưng mà vẫn phải biết từ khóa để
tra đúng.
bộ nhớ. Tôi có nhớ cái này. Phông chữ á
phông chữ phông chữ này phông chữ bình
thường mà nhỉ. Tôi không dùng cái phông
chữ đặc biệt đâu. Rõ ràng có nhiều cái
hồi trước xem mấy cái hay. Nhưng cái này
đang dùng phông chữ bình thường đấy. Hồi
trước là tôi nhớ ở quả tôi cũng màu mè
dùng cái phông Monalisa xong rồi à xong
rồi gì à file code gì đó. Còn cái này
phông bình thường thôi.
Tôi chẳng qua đang để màn hình to đấy. À
tôi chưa dùng.
À
tuy khai báo giống hệt nhau nhưng mà
không cùng địa chỉ nên là dấu bằng bằng
không được. Thì so sánh dùng equal để mà
có thể bằng được. Hôm qua còn chơi lớn
là hôm qua mình thử dùng kiểu như này
dùng to cha array. Không biết mình
reverse lại được không? Chắc không
reverse được.
Thế không sao mình sẽ
à thôi cái này cũng được không sao
này sao bằng được đúng không
Ồ hợp lý nhỉ? Ừ
trình là tôi thì tôi cũng a kiểu kiểu
cài mọi thứ cho mồm mè. Tôi vẫn nhớ tôi
vẫn nhớ. Không biết mấy ông xem chắc là
không quen tôi thời đầu đấy đâu. Vì hồi
đấy tôi mới 52 thôi. Tôi còn để cái hình
nền kiểu di hảnh logo đại bàng J2 này.
Đấy xong rồi còn nó là back nó video cơ.
X background nó sẽ kiểu mờ mờ mờ mờ dần.
Đấy, xong rồi. À dùng cái bởi vì đang
dùng Win nên là dùng cả phần mềm để mà
làm nó là phần mềm class gì đó làm cho
mờ mờ cái a mờ cái kiểu gõ cái gõ code
cái editor hoặc là IDE này. Xong rồi đấy
xem cái video ở đằng sau. Hô đấy còn một
lần nữa còn vừa ngồi code vừa xem cái
video đằng sau là DJ Soda nữa đấy. Hơi
trẻ trâu.
fure hôm qua có đề cập đây. Đầu tiên là
mình sẽ khai báo rõ ràng nó là một cái
gọi là
gọi là gì nhỉ? New này là tạo một object
mới. Ừ nhưng mà nó không có từ khóa nó
nó chỉ là new object mới thôi đúng
không? Tạo bằng OK rồi không dùng không
tạo bằng literal đúng không? Đấy nhưng
mà mình dùng cái hàm intern thì nó cũng
sẽ đẩy vào pool đấy.
Ok. Và cái này khi mà cũng dùng từ pịa
cái này là à đâu chính xác là thằng S8
tuy là khai báo intern nhưng mà
nhưng mà thằng S8 lại không bị đẩy vào
P. F8 vẫn nằm ở ngoài p, chỉ có S9 mới
nằm ở trong pu thôi. Ồ,
đời.
Ok, không hiểu lắm, không sao.
địa chỉ đâu anh. Nó chỉ so sánh địa chỉ
khi dùng từ khóa New thôi ạ. Hả? S1, S2.
Thế á? Ông đừng lừa tôi nhá.
F1 với2 này không phải so sánh cùng địa
chỉ á.
Vừa mới học cái này so sánh cụng địa chỉ
xong.
Đâu xem à có người bảo tôi là
không phải
so sánh địa chỉ
đúng hay sai?
nửa.
Bình tĩnh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh.
object thì địa chỉ bộ nhớ ok
này nhưng mà với object
là mình sẽ so sánh địa chỉ ok
thuật thì so sánh Nhưng mà
đây giá trị ok giữ giữ nguyên nhé.
diễn giải ấy không ông. Bây giờ tôi đang
học nửa anh đương nhiên là có từ tiếng
Anh chương ngành thì vẫn giữ nguyên nhá.
Bây giờ ông bảo tôi hoàn toàn tiếng Anh
tôi lú đấy.
bảo rồi ông đừng coi tôi là tôi đang tôi
đang dạy mấy ông này. Cái việc là tôi
đang giỏi hay gì đó. Tôi đang học đang
học mà học từ đây rồi mới buổi hai à đâu
nhờ buổi ba trên mặt lý thuyết. Đấy. Thế
nên là mày mấy ông đừng
đừng kiểu đặt rất nhiều kỳ vọng. Đấy,
không sao mấy ông Tôi nghĩ là mấy ông ở
đây nếu mấy ông nói thế chứng tỏ mấy ông
giỏi hơn tôi rồi đấy. Mấy ông nên tự hào
xịn.
Đây có kiểu hôm qua là kiểu cộng này
nữa. Cái kiểu cộng này chắc chắn là học
à không thằng Java tôi chẳng nhớ thằng
nào ra đời trước. Thằng JavaScript hay
thằng Java trước nữa,
chắc cũng tham khảo của nhau. Ừ không
sao, quên là chuyện bình thường mà. Hôm
hôm trước tôi bắt ông em tôi phải ngồi
hiểu kiểu phải ngồi đọc lại và phải hiểu
để mà giải thích lại cho tôi một cái
này. Chính nó
là thằng thường xuyên dùng. Chắc chắn là
mấy ông là người dùng thường xuyên. Thậm
chí bây giờ bảo tôi dạy PP lại có những
cái mà tôi vẫn sẽ phải có tra lại tài
liệu thôi. Bởi vì rõ ràng là mình dùng
như một thói quen chứ mình không nói
không hiểu bản chất thì nó không đúng
nhưng mà chắc chắn là không nhớ kỹ lý
thuyết thì đúng. mình chỉ dùng thôi. Đấy
và đặc biệt là thực tế dự án thực tế có
bao giờ gặp mấy cái cây kiểu bằng bằng
các thứ ít tôi nghĩ là ít đến chính là
tôi làm PP nó cũng không phải so sánh
thường là bọn tôi so sánh tới ba dấu
bằng thì chắc chắn nó là cùng kiểu giá
trị với cùng kiểu cùng cùng giá trị và
cùng kiểu dữ liệu. Đấy, hai dấu bằng đã
rất ít rồi.
niệm về run time này. Run time này. Xong
rồi. Hôm qua bạn đấy cũng có nói về có
bạn nói về comply time là thời và lúc
kiểu lúc mà kiểu tạo ra file class ạ.
À đâu cái run time này lúc chạy thực tế
và comply là lúc mà biên dịch đấy
nên lúc biên dịch nó sẽ khác nữa cơ. Cái
này còn để xem nào. Ming với các thứ thử
à đấy thời gian thực thi và thời gian
chạy. Ok.
trông đây. Tôi à tôi đang định bảo tôi
xem quen xem kiểu bên
bên kiểu gì nhỉ? Cái trang Mdown. Nhưng
mà cái này vẽ theo kiểu MC down nhưứ
không phải.
chịu một tí. Đợi tí. Ồ, ok.
Ừ
hàm qua đấy
nên nên dùng hàm qua các thứ thứ thứ ok
nhưng mà thế này chưa đủ bởi vì là hôm
nay
hôm nay a dùng cái a dùng cái gợi ý của
AI đợi tí tôi tắt cái
cái này tắt. đi
đỡ khó chịu dùng cái a của ai này nó gợi
ý
nó đã tăng một tí vào trong đây auto
boxing và unboxing này và cả cái này các
thứ thứ nữa nên tôi sẽ sửa lại ngày buổi
một và buổi hai một tí. Đấy thì hôm nay
tính vẫn là day 2 mà đúng không? Đấy
chúng ta sẽ ngồi sửa lại buổi một buổi
hai một tí.
thông chơi hẳn con này không nhá. Thôi
hẳn con này đi. Sửa lại đâ 1 và day 2
cho tôi cho phù hợp hơn
với tài liệu.
Ờ
hiện tại thì mình đang tốn
20 tầm 20 đô cho antirapity này. À
không, đấy là tôi được 3 tháng 50.000, 3
tháng đầu 50.000 thì phải. Còn những
tháng sau sẽ tính giá như thế. À nhưng
cái antigravity này ngoài việc mấy ông
thấy đang dùng kiểu mấy cái model mọi
thứ cũng chưa thấy dấu hiệu limit đúng
không? Sáng nay thực ra tôi vừa bị con
limit con Cloude phát nữa. Nhưng mà sao
lúc ấy chuyển qua dùng trên mini Pro mọi
thứ vẫn chẳng vấn đề gì cả mà dùng hình
như là chỉ một tí con này nó lại hết
limit bởi vì nó reset sau 4 tiếng đấy
nên là gần như là và cái điểm hay đó là
như hôm qua tôi có nói đó là ông mua 20
đô đúng không nhưng mà ông dùng cho được
cả family rõ ràng nó không hề đề cập cái
vụ đấy ở trong cái phần gói của nó nhưng
mà ông sẽ được 2T 2TV
gói này ví dụ là Gemini Pro hay gì gì đó
nhưng mà tôi ít dùng nên là tôi không
quan tâm lắm nhưng đại khái thì tôi mua
là để về code mà đúng không? Thì rõ ràng
là tôi từng mua cho con
Cuso với cả Green Search rồi thì tôi
thấy là nó tốn hơn 20 đô.
miễn phí thì nó sẽ nó sau một tuần thì
nó mới reset. Nghĩa là nó sẽ chỉ có
lượng nhất định là limit trong một tuần
thôi. Nhưng mà với bản mất phí này thì
sau 4 tiếng nó reset rồi nên là ít ít
khi bị limit cái này lắm.
ý
tôi là sửa code và
Bolei
vừa làm đã.
Cái này thì tôi không hồi trước là tôi
đã từng kiểu chắc là ai cũng đã từng
kiểu dạng là
dùng một cái trích nào đó kiểu
à có gì cần thay đổi sửa lại code hai
file đó vì đó là example
cho tài liệu này.
trước mình sẽ không quan tâm nhiều bản
quyền lắm hoặc là mình không có điều
kiện để mà mua bản quyền đấy. Nhưng mà
càng về sau này tôi kiểu mình làm đép mà
nên mình cũng trân trọng nên là mình sẽ
không kiểu lách luật mình không các thứ
nữa mà tôi còn nghĩ là một phần là đây
là tài khoản ví dụ hiện tại mấy ông đang
thấy logo đây luôn này. Đây chính là tài
khoản kiểu chính chủ của tôi luôn đấy.
thì mình không nên kiểu
dùng tài khoản chính chủ mình xong rồi
giao dịch hay là làm cái gì đó nó kiểu
lách luật các thứ thứ đúng không ạ? Tự
nhiên nh đâu phía sau làm ảnh hưởng đến
chính tài khoản của mình. Nhưng tốt nhất
là kiểu nếu có thể thì cứ mua thôi. Đấy
hiện tại tôi mua đấy chứ tôi mua kiểu
mua thẳng từ Google luôn. Tôi không
thông qua bên trung gian nào cả.
đang dùng thứ nhất là Windows thì chắc
là vẫn chưa mua bản quyền Windows à và
cái gì nhỉ ờ du lingo à dual lingo thì
đúng là mua
mua cùng với family thì đúng là nó rẻ
hơn thế thôi.
có phải là lậu đâu. Vì rõ ràng là nó hỏi
ông ông có muốn trả tiền không, ông chọn
không chứ nó không phải là ông đang dùng
lậu hay là ông đang crack nó. Không
phải. Window thì đúng. Đúng là đa số là
crack. Tôi tôi không nhớ là tôi crack
hay là tôi active cái gì đó nữa. Anti
Gravity mình vừa nói là sẽ tầm 20 đô.
Thực ra đấy vẫn là tùy tài khoản bạn
nhá.
cái tài khoản Google của bạn ấy. Ví dụ
là của sếp tôi là được miễn phí tháng
đầu này. Những tháng sau mà mất tiền thì
vẫn 20 đô thôi. Đấy
viết lại. Đấy viết lại hai file rồi.
Thôi mình sẽ ngồi ôn lại cái day 1 day
2. Nào
lưu giá trị trong stack không thể là
nun. Tốn ít bộ nhớ không có method
stack. Hôm qua mình có đề cập với hit và
stack đúng không? H stack cả hai đều bộ
nhớ đúng không? Đấy. Ok.
không? Nếu mà dịch thu thì sẽ không được
nun.
mua mấy cái gói này còn được Google One.
Đấy nhưng mà mấy ông thực ra không dùng
tốt Google One hoặc là thực ra tôi không
biết mấy ông dùng có đi hay không. Nhưng
đại khái tôi hồi trước tôi dùng khá là
vắt dùng từ vắt thì cũng đúng. Nghĩa là
Google One có một cái hồi trước có một
cái ngoài lợi thế là kiểu nó tăng cái
dung lượng của ra ý.
Nó có một lợi thế nữa mà ít người dùng
đó là được liên hệ với hỗ trợ bên
Google. Đấy,
bây giờ hình như là người ta hình như
cũng bắt đầu đông người dùng và cũng có
vài người spam hay sao ấy. Chắc là nó
limit rồi. Và nó cũng gọi là có thể tôi
cảm thấy giống như là dùng AI trả lời
hơn, kiểu nó bị khô cứng nhắc ấy hoặc là
cũng bị giới hạn quyền. Chứ hồi trước
tôi từng nhắn cho bên đấy rồi nhớ bên
đấy, bên đấy còn gọi hẳn dep để mà dep
hỗ trợ tôi cơ. Và đấy kiểu vãi trưởng
báo bấc xong rồi các thứ rồi. Google
Support hỗ trợ. Đấy mấy ông được nói
chuyện với Google Support nó vinh dự
đúng không ạ? Đấy Google One có một cái
điều kiện như thế ở trong cái chính sách
của họ.
Còn bây giờ có vẻ đồng lượng người dùng
Google One kết hợp việc là có thể nó
giới hạn theo IP cũng n giống như là
kiểu mình lạm dụng Facebook hay là các
nền tảng khác kiểu spam về cái contact
của nó support nó quá nên thành ra nó
cũng limit là riêng theo cái địa chỉ IP
Việt Nam thì nó sẽ dùng boss để trả lời
kiểu thế
vì mình muốn tăng cái dung lượng Google
Drive thôi lên 100 GB thôi nhưng mà dùng
mua bất kỳ gói nào của Google One cũng
đều có cái vụ là được support đấy.
lưu trong stack. Cái này lưu trong hit
đúng không? Có thể là nun dùng trong
collection. À đây có bạn hôm qua nhắc
đến kiểu khái niệm collection xong rồi
nhắc đến cái gì nhở?
từ gì ấ nên là chắc là để dần dần sau sẽ
biết. Elite này, Hmap này. Uầy, cái này
chắc chắn là mình sẽ phải dần dần biết.
Có method hữu ích. Ừ ok. Method thì có
biết dần rồi. Uầy có character á. Ừ thế
mà hôm trước mình chỉ biết tưởng là cha
viết hoa thôi chứ là nó là chaor. Ok
nghĩa là kiểu viết đầy đủ. Viết hai chữ
đâu. Ok được. Chắc là có flash các thứ
nữa được phép nun này.
Auto boxing là tự động chuyển. Uầy tự
động chuyển từ cái này cái này. Cái này
hôm trước chưa đề cập này. Đâu xem nào.
Cái này bằng này thì cái thằng cũ này
vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên ra thằng nguyên thủy.
Còn thằng này sẽ tự động chuyển thành
thằng mới. Ừm. Nghe hợp lý. Về cái này
bản chất cái này giống như là kiểu ghi
như này thôi mà đúng không? Ok được.
Unbox
à thế bây giờ bình thường auto rồi unbox
nghĩa là đổi ngược lại. À
à đổi ngược lại. Ok biến thành. Có
trường hợp nào mà hiểu mình tự nhiên
mình phải làm ngược lại như này không
nhỉ?
này chẳng biết dùng nó nó là kiểu dữ
liệu khác biệt với PP thôi. Mình đang
cần xem tại sao các thứ thôi.
Đúng tự nhiên quay lại thì nó sẽ kiểu
không được phép nun thì nó sẽ gây nguy
hiểm. Đúng.
bình thường dùng bằng để so sánh.
tượng với nhau. Ừ cũng giống như là
thằng string ở kia đúng không nhỉ? Kiểu
bằng new new string đúng không?
Không phải cùng cái địa chỉ
nên thành ra bằng không được. Phải dùng
hàm equal đúng không?
được cách có thể bằng bằng có thể chu.
được. Tôi không biết được mấy ông có
biết vụ này không cơ kiểu c lưu ý cái
này này. Lần đầu tôi nghe luôn ạ. Con gị
vãi chưởng. [tiếng cười]
Riêng trường hợp này thì bằng lại bằng
chua. Ok.
trách nhiệm vui cho các bạn. Ừ, tôi sẽ
ngồi làm
làm cao hút đấy. Tổng hợp những cái mà
tôi đã cảm thấy kiểu bất ngờ vì Java.
Tôi cho chính mấy ông chơi từ Java mấy
ông chơi luôn. Ví dụ cái này này, tôi
hỏi ông em tôi ông em chưa chắc trả lời
được đâu. Đấy, đúng không? Cứ khẳng định
luôn là thời đi học đa số trừ khi thầy
nào cũng kiểu cũng kiểu vui tính giống
tôi không biết được. Đấy
sẽ không ai kiểu chỉ cho mấy ông bởi vì
cái này giống cái mẹo kiểu chích chích
hay các thứ nó nhỏ nhỏ nó chẳng phải một
cái to để mà kiến thức Hàn Lâm để mà dạy
ấy đúng không? Đấy hay đấy. Ông kia đừng
ông kia quên đi nhá.
được. Hôm nào tôi sẽ
mở mấy cái kiểu trắc nghiệm cao hút anh
em ngồi chơi với nhau nhở.
hồi trước nếu mấy ông từng tham gia cái
khóa mấy khóa học cũ của tôi, tôi từng
làm mấy cái trang nghiệm trong kiểu cuối
mỗi bài vui vui rồi đúng không? Nhưng mà
mấy cái đấy nó sẽ kiến thức đấy có thể
mà mấy ông học rồi mấy ông kiểu gì cũng
biết nên thành ra nó kiểu không vui nữa.
Thì rõ ràng cái này phải là rất ít người
biết thì nó mới vui kiểu mình lúc đấy
mình sẽ kiểu cảm thấy bị thách thức ấy
nó mới hay. Đấy do mấy ông thích dùng
cái chơi mấy cái
một là hackthon à hai là cái cta à tôi
nhớ CTA mà đúng không?
cái kiểu dạng giống kiểu hack ấ đ nhá
CTA
À
tôi nhớ
có khái niệm kiểu thử thách
trong giới công nghệ
kiểu hack CTA đúng không?
Đúng nó có thể hackathon nhưng ý tôi
không phải là mỗi hackathon. Đây phải
như này này. CTF này kiểu kiểu này
CTF nó thiên về thử thách tức chị ạ. nó
một cái gì khó. Đương nhiên là đa số là
nó sẽ liên quan đến bảo mật các thứ như
này. Nhưng mà mình có thể rộng hơn mà.
Đấy nó giống kiểu challeng các thứ thôi.
Đấy nghĩa là một cái thử thách nào đó
để kiểu giợ để cho mấy ông cùng làm cùng
đấy. Thử thách nhau hay mà. Hồi trước là
J2 team cũng có cái trang CTF mấy ông
cũng làm hết rồi gì á.
Nhưng mà cái đấy thiên về kiến thức về
web và một tí về bảo mật hay các thứ
thứ.
Còn đây kiến thức mà chính mà chúng ta
đang học, chúng ta đang làm đúng không?
Cùng nhớ đặc biệt trong híp. Ừ. Tái sử
dụng string giống nhau tiết kiệm bụi
nhớ. Uầy. Đấy, nó sửa lại như này nhìn
trông nó dễ hiểu hơn ấy.
này trông có vẻ chi tiết hơn.
kiểu này không sao không ạ
luôn tạo
bộ object mới trong h ngoài pool object
mới ngoài pool này thêm object này phone
là khát địa chỉ phone là p với hip khác
nhau đúng đó sẽ khát địa chỉ luôn đúng
Ở đây là dùng từ nội dung thay vì giá
trị nhỉ? Nhưng mà value dịch ra là giá
trị mà nhỉ.
bạn kia nói m table là có thể thay đổi
đúng không?
Còn imu là không thể đổi bất biến đúng
không?
báo cụ thể và nó cố định giống kiểu
constant kiểu này. Về sau nó sẽ bớt bị
lỗi đúng không? Trad safety rồi các thứ
chứ còn PP là kiểu đang kiểu biến này
đang làm kiểu dữ liệu này rồi cho gán
biến này làm cái giá trị và kiểu dữ liệu
khác luôn cũng được. Đấy
cái này là nun boer exception đúng
không? À đây đây đây vừa đề cập xong
đấy.
rồi này.
Ok bây giờ tôi sẽ sang thử buổi ba nhá.
Anh em sẵn sàng chưa ạ?
Nồi chuỗi tạo mới chậm và được nhanh.
Ờ
kiếm
này cũng là thinh kinh nhá.
cập nhật à kiểm tra.
gì bù lớn đâu. Thậm chí là có dùng tiếng
ngại Anh đâu. Dùng tiếng Việt mà đúng
không? Thấy là kiểu nói chuyện như giao
tiếp bình thường thôi đúng không?
để mà học PP là à học OP là khá là rõ là
nó còn thêm nhiều cái nữa cơ. Lúc mà lúc
mà kiểu đọc về cái tư duy cốt lõi này
công nhận nhiều cái hay cả lưu ý ở dưới
này này. Miên tắc vàng các thứ như này
hay phết.
nào.
Có demo rồi này.
nào dùng khi nào dùng cái nào các thứ.
Cái này cứ bị nhảy xuống dưới khó chịu
cực.
Chưa giải thích rõ. Chưa giải thích tr
save là gì. Chưa phần tầm tóm tắt rõ
ràng.
Ok.
Ui, có thêm ví dụ trong SQL building
nữa. Uầy, xịn thế. Xem nào. String
Builder và String Buffer.
Hiểu về bất biến khi nào sử dụng một
trong hai đúng không? So sánh hiệu năng.
Ok. bất biến
bình thường cái này cộng thêm sau nối
chũa string cũ bị bỏ đi tạo giác cho
cái này vừa nãy là mình đọc rồi nó là
grapit collector tức là kiểu kiểu thu
gom giác kiểu thế đúng không?
Xong rồi string bằng string cũ cộng với
world. Sau nối như thế này.
string bình thường mình sẽ khai báo
string
builder. Ok. Hợp lý đấy. Hợp lý đấy.
Thay đổi trực tiếp được không? tạo mới
nhanh hơn, không trưng
mà nó sẽ không an toàn đúng không? Bởi
vì như vừa nãy mình nói là để cho nó nên
là bất biến thì mình sẽ luôn biết được à
nó lúc đầu là gì thì về sau mình sẽ biết
là nó sẽ mãi là như thế đúng không? Còn
bây giờ thì cái này là phải xem theo.
Đúng rồi. Nó thay đổi được thì phải dựa
theo cái run time s dựa theo cái việc nó
chạy nó sẽ như nào đúng không? Thì lúc
đấy mình lại đoán mò giống PP thôi. Cái
đoạn này giống PP tôi tôi nghĩ tôi hiểu
đoạn này. Thậm chí còn đa luồng nữa nhỉ.
Ừ đa luồng nữa. Tức là ám chỉ là kiểu
bây giờ có thể thằng này ghi vào trong
chính cái bộ nhớ đấy đúng không? Có thể
thay đổi
bình tĩnh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh.
Chưa chưa xuống bình tĩnh đợi đợi đợi
đã. Đâu gốc này. Ok này. Thêm dữ điệu
này. Appen trông hay nhỉ. Appen cũng
kiểu giống hệt làm việc với mảng luôn ý.
Thật. Up. Hàm open này tôi còn nhớ là
giống kiểu trong jigory à kiểu làm việc
với HTML JavaScript
insert à insert là như nào 5 Java là như
nào?
Nghĩa là
sau P sau insert. Uầy cái này phải chạy
thử mới hiểu ấy. Cái delete này thì tôi
nghĩ là tôi nghĩ là cái năm này là
à đấy nó offset nghĩa là
ơ pen này là như nào? Là cứ thêm ở cuối
đúng không? Con này là tại vị trí thứ
bao nhiêu? Nghĩa là sẽ có trường hợp ghi
đè à
đúng không? Tôi nghĩ là nó sẽ ghi đè.
cái chỗ nào đấy thì xong rồi sẽ đẩy
những thằng kia về đằng sau đúng không?
Nghĩ thế reverse đâu xem
đây nó sẽ chỉ insert thôi.
À ghi đẻ set à ừ tôi nghĩa là gọi là
chèn thêm vào đúng không? Insert là đang
là chèn đấy. Chèn thêm vào vị trí đ bao
nhiêu? Delete là xóa từ từ bao nhiêu đến
bao nhiêu. Ok. Reverse là kiểu đảo ngược
lại đúng không? Đảo ngược lại kiểu sắp
xếp các thứ.
Ồ string buffer string builder cộng red
save. Cái th save này tôi có nhớ về khái
niệm trúc mà
tải cái gì nó cũng bảo tr nhỉ.
Non trap save với tr hình như PP cũng có
thì phải.
Nếu lúc đấy tôi cũng chưa hiểu cái th
đợi tôi một tí. Thre xếp có phải là nó
liên quan đến đa luồng
an toàn khi đa luồng không?
Để tớ hỏi lại nhá. Xếp trong lập trình
nghĩa là gì?
niệm đa luồng nên thạ không quan tâm này
lắm đứ nh thình thoảng có đa luồng theo
kiểu là kill chạy song song hay gì gì đó
red truy cập đồng thời mà vẫn cho kết
quả đúng nhất quán không gây lỗi dữ
liệu, không phụ thuộc vào thứ tự. Ầy,
không phụ thuộc thứ tự là cũng ghê đấy.
Vấn đề xuất hiện vì đọc ghi cung chung
cái stat state
khi điều này xảy ra gặp các thảm họa
kinh điển như race condition. Great
Condition này. Hồi trước tôi từng làm
cái vụ ở công ty, tôi không biết tôi
từng chia sẻ mấy ông chưa. Xong rồi bọn
tôi phải chơi. Ừ đúng rồi. Nó cũng phải
tí. Nó liên quan database là nhiều mà
trong PP liên quan ray condition
database nhiều. Thì hồi đấy bọn tôi phải
chơi cái trò là thay vì lock lại cả cái
table thì đương nhiên là lock chết ngay.
Thì không nên mình phải lock theo theo
bản ghi. Thế nên là kèm luôn phải kèm
theo một cái điều kiện nào đó. Phải we
theo một cái điều kiện nào đó. Đấy
quả đấy hay phết.
Gọi là log nhưng mà lock động đấy. Lock
dynamic thay vì lock cứng hot lock. Hot
lock thì thằng khác không truy cập vào
được thì cũng không ổn. Đương nhiên là
cũng có hotlock theo kiểu read nhưng mà
mình vẫn muốn là kiểu bây giờ giả sử bây
giờ ông cứ hình dung là ông chuyển tiền
ngân hàng có rất nhiều người cùng chuyển
vào số tài khoản ông cùng lúc rõ ràng là
rõ ràng là điều đấy điều hoàn toàn có
thể xảy ra nhưng nghĩa là chỉ nhiều
người cùng chuyển tiền ông cùng một lúc
là điều bình thường đúng không được phép
đúng không nhưng mà rõ ràng tại cái thời
điểm đấy là database đang đang cập nhật
cái số tiền của ông rồi thì rõ ràng là
nó phải chính xác Chắc nó phải là kiểu
tránh việc là nhiều người cùng kiểu ghi
đè vào quá nó sẽ bị loạn đúng không? Ví
dụ ông đang 10.000 rõ ràng nó bảo cộng
thêm 10.000 nữa đấy. Nhưng mà có rất
nhiều thằng cộng cộng rồi thậm chí còn
thằng trừ trừ nữa. Cùng tại 1 giây đấy
chẳng hạn thì rõ ràng là mình sẽ phải
thêm những cái điều kiện nào đó hoặc là
mình phải đôi khi là phải còn phụ thuộc
vào cái thứ tự ưu tiên hay à thứ tự chạy
nghĩa cộng trước rồi trừ rồi cộng cộng
trừ hay vân vân vân. Đấy các thứ nói
chung là đấy do mà tôi bắt đầu hiểu tại
sao các hệ thống ngân hàng đều dùng Java
rồi để nó liên quan đến tress save các
thứ này để tránh mấy cái
kiểu đa luồng nhá nó vẫn phải đảm bảo về
tính a đấy gọi là tính gì nhở constit à
consistant nó tính a
tính chặt chẽ chẽ à không phải tính chất
chẽ nó tính gì nhở? Consistent
tính
consist
vẫn dịch lại cho tôi.
Đúng là nhất quán dữ liệu đấy đây đúng
tính nhất quán
ơ mình viết đúng kìa. Uầy
à không không đúng lắm đúng không? Không
không không đúng đắn. [tiếng cười] Không
sao đấy nó hiểu mà. Đấy,
tính nhất quán. Đúng rồi.
Thế ra tôi hỏi mấy ông để mấy ông trả
lời thôi.
Kết quả các thứ thứ
một đoạn code được
gọi là tr khi đảm bảo một trong các
chiến liên sau hoặc kết hợp
ồ nghĩa chỉn một thôi cũng được đúng
không? Không có share state.
trên kênh tip. Đúng rồi. Hình như là anh
có theo dõi kênh đấy rõ ràng kêu là tip
ra script nhưng mà thật ra đề cập rất
nhiều cái nó cũng chả lế ngon ra script
gì cả.
Mà nó có phải tip đâu. Nó rõ ràng nó là
một kiểu một kênh ebook hơn một kênh
kiểu chia sẻ kiến thức hơn. Týp là theo
kiểu mẹo vặt mà đúng không?
Mỗi tr làm việc với dữ liệu riêng là
chiến lược tôi đánh giá cao nhất vì đơn
giản bền vững.
Ừ nhưng mà rất khó vì rõ ràng là dữ liệu
thường hay dữ liệu chung cho tiết kiệm
về chi phí rồi rất nhiều cái. Bởi vì nếu
mà không thì dữ liệu kiểu độc lập thì
thực ra là nó cũng không ổn.
Đ nói cơ sở dữ liệu nhá. Đó cơ sở dữ
liệu thì bây giờ mình tách ra thì rõ
ràng là một bên này cập nhật là tăng lên
10.000, bên này cập nhật tăng lên 20.000
Nhìn xong rồi sẽ vào với nhau như nào
đúng không? Đồng bộ với nhau như nào?
Dữ liệu chỉ đọc không bao giờ thay đổi
sau khi tạo cũng một kiểu. Đấy thì hồi
trước có cái chơi kiểu đấy thường ấy lưu
gọi là bảng lịch sử giao dịch đúng
không? Đấy các thứ đấy mình có thể có
thế nghĩa là mình sẽ dựa theo nghĩa là
nếu mà có một cái lỗi gì đó phát sinh
trong quá trình mà mình à tại kiểu bất
đồng bộ đây đúng không? các thứ mình vẫn
có một thứ để vai date lại đi kiểm tra
lại là nó đang đúng hay đang sai và mình
có thể còn kiểu gọi như là mình có thể
sửa được nó ấ ông ông hiểu không nghĩa
luôn có một cái sổ nhậ ký một cái quyền
để ghi lại toàn bộ những cái đấy thì
mình còn biết được mình còn sửa
vào gọi là insert thôi, không được
update cũng không được delete.
xong rồi transition nữa. Hồi đấy tôi nói
là à tôi có nghe cái có một anh bảo là
lạm dụng cái đấy là một cái bẫy. Bởi vì
bởi vì rõ ràng là bây giờ ông cứ hình
dung là
làm một cái thứ đấy tận năm bước đi xong
đến bước thứ ba nó lỗi nó robách nó kiểu
khôi phục lại. Ok đương nhiên là về dữ
liệu thì ông sẽ không bị sai nữa nhưng
mà rõ ràng là ông sẽ phải ngồi mò xem nó
đến bước nào nó lỗi. Đấy, bình thường
mọi khi là mình lưu ở DB thì mình còn
biết được à ví dụ à đến bảng thứ ba thì
nó vẫn còn lưu, còn bảng thứ tư nó không
lưu nữa thì mình có biết. Giờ nhiều
người thì bảo là thôi bắn lock lên thì
lock thì nó cũng giống như một cái DB
thôi. Nghĩa là chỉ là bản chất là mình
vẫn phải đánh dấu ở một cái chỗ nào đó.
Ông hiểu không? Như rõ trung quy thì nó
vẫn là một cái kiểu một cách khác thôi.
Chẳng qua mình ghi vào DB ở chỗ khác
kiểu thế. Đôi khi là log còn có vấn đề
nhá. Hồi trước kênh blog ở trên công ty
tôi vấn đề xong rồi hồi đấy thử muốn
ngồi trang ngược lại king lock để để
biết được kiểu gọi là dữ liệu các thứ
thứ như nào klock không đấy có vấn đề
nên thành ra cũng không trai được nên
thành ra là kiểu
lúc đấyên lại quay lại câu chuyện vừa
nãy tôi nói cái bài toán này này là khi
mà ông làm mà ông không có bảng nào đó
để deate để đối chiếu ấy king lock cũng
mà nói chung là kênh lock không phải là
một kênh ch một kênh đạ đáng tin cậy để
mà ông phải tin vào nó để dùng nó để mà
validate các thứ. Lock chỉ là lock cảm
chỉ là tại thời điểm này thì mình còn
theo dõi được thôi chứ không không nên
dùng cái log là một kênh để mà xác thực
dữ liệu, xác thực thông tin.
Đấy
mấy ông chắc là tôi tôi nói thế thôi
nhưng mà tôi nghĩ mấy ông có thể đã đi
làm hết rồi và cũng biết được tôi đang
mùa ru qua mắt thợ rồi nhưng mà tôi vẫn
nhắc lại bởi vì đôi khi là cái cách mà
tôi chia sẻ cũng là để cho mấy ông a
à nếu mà thấy tôi nói sai thì còn phản
bác lại kiểu mày chém gió sai rồi đấy
thì tôi lại biết được là mình c nói sai
cũng hay mà đúng không?
đang có kênh kênh này tên là học nhá,
không phải dạy nhá. Mình cùng nhau học
tốt mày.
Dùng các nguyên tử cho ngôn ngữ hoặc
time cung cấp cũng được.
Dữ liệu chỉ sống trong một th nhất định.
Ừ, nghĩa giống kiểu biến cục bộ đúng
không?
À trong này còn không gọi là biến nữa
bởi vì rõ ràng là trong PP nó sẽ khái
niệm là biến bởi vì rõ ràng nó là nó là
biến tức là nó có thể thay đổi. Còn đây
là sẽ mang thi hướng kiểu hằng số hơn.
Đấy rõ rằng constant kiểu mặc định mặc
định constant luôn.
X không đồng nghĩa với nhanh lock càng
nhiều hệ thống càng dễ nghẽn. Đúng một
hệ thống tre nhưng thiết kế kém vẫn bị
chậm và không scale được. Đúng kiểu nó
bị kiểu đồn đẩy nó đợi cái này chạy cái
đợi kia chạy thì thành ra lại không phải
đa luồng nữa. Đấy
nó thiết kế có chủ đích một class hôm
nay tret ngày hôm sau thể biến thành để
là có thể phá nếu chưa thực sự cần thì
Concurrency nó chưa đề cập từ
concurrency đúng không?
Nãy là tôi chưa thể thấy nó đề cập đúng
không?
đừng vội đa luồng. Ừ nghĩa không cần
chạy đồng thời cũng một lúc đúng không?
Ôi hay phết đấy. Nghĩa thỉnh thoảng nó
may mà thỉnh thoảng nó có một vài từ
chuyên ngành này nhá. Toàn bộ tiếng Anh
thì chắc tôi tôi vẫn biết tiếng Anh nhá.
Nhưng mà chắc chắn là mày không biết
được. Đây mấy từ chuyên ngành mà đúng
không? Chứ chứ chứ
nó không
hỏi như nào nhỉ? Bình thường tôi xem
phim mà nghe nhạc có nhiều nhưng mà mấy
cái từ nay ch nó không vừa gặp trừ khi
ông xem thể loại gì thôi.
Khi đã đa luồng hãy ưu tiên thiết kế
tránh share state
hơn là vá lỗi bằng lock.
Ừm ok. Ui, mấy kiến thức này nó ứng dụng
cho tư duy lập trình ấy chứ không phải
mỗi Java hay là PP nói chung đúng không?
Hay mà
cứ cái này là gì? Cứ đồng cứ đây gọi là
cứ đồng bộ hết đúng không? Đây xử lý
đồng bộ đồng bộ hết cho lành à?
Đấy.
thích nói chuyện với thằng CHVT hơn
thằng Jini rất nhiều này. Nó nhớ nó nhớ
mình đã nói gì cho dù rõ ràng là đây là
một cái đoạn chat khác. Đấy.
thì tôi biết rồi. Tôi biết parallel song
song rồi. Đấy.
kiểu cứ cho là cá nhân hóa customiz các
thứ thứ để mà để mà trả lời cho mình phù
hợp đúng không? Thế mà có ông vẫn bảo
tôi là kiểu nói chuyện với chatt bị đần
xong rồi thích Gemini hơn chịu.
riêng về code thì có thể thằng khác ăn
đứt chat JVT nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy chatt
tôi vẫn trả lời mọi thứ rất dễ hiểu và
cả nhân hóa rất tốt.
Cho dù gần đây nó à có một thời gian nó
nịnh thì tôi khá khó chịu và gần đây nó
bắt đầu
xưng hô cũng hơi loạn lên tôi cũng không
thích lắm nhưng thôi không sao.
không nói rồi nhưng mà đang nói là về
kiểu đây đấy thì mấy ông mấy ông phải
hiểu nhá tôi dùng cloud cloue hay thậm
chí là dùng để code đúng không? Đấy
nhưng mà mình đang cần một con trợ lý ào
để mà mình ngồi hỏi đáp như này này để
thay tra Google thôi đúng không? Thì rõ
ràng thì thì con này nó hơn cái con
Gemini kiểu đần vãi trường kia. Tôi từng
dùng con Gemini từ thời dùng ba nhá. À
ba này Gemini từ đầu này xong rồi còn
dùng cả copilot. C VOT của Microsoft ấ
quá tệ đấy. A thư các bạn rất lâu rồi
không dùng cot không biết nó thông minh
hơn chưa đấy.
hiểu sai vì nó thường
dữ liệu này, hệ thống phân tán này, cả
thiết kế chương trình.
Tôi không thích lắm bởi vì tôi thường
anh bảo với nó là phản biện nhiều lên
đừng có nịnh nữa. Rồi bây giờ nó dễ luôn
nói câu là tôi sẽ nói thẳng có chính
kiến chứ không kiểu nịnh nữa. Cứ nhắc đi
lại buồn cười.
việc hệ thống luôn luôn tuân thủ các quy
tắc đã đặt ra
bất kể có bao nhiêu thao tác hay truy
cập. Ừ. Hồi đấy tôi đặt tôi ép nó là
kiểu kiểu gọi như là 30% đồng thuận, 70%
là phản đối ấ đấy để cho nó ném đá mình
để cho mình nhìn thấy điểm mù của bản
thân ý.
ra bất kể có thao tác hay truy cập đồng
thời. Ừm, nghĩa là chỉ có bao nhiêu thứ
x vào dù thế nào nữa thì mình không được
mâu thuẫn. Mình vẫn kiểu up vẫn phải
update đúng dữ liệu này. Đấy dù nó chạy
trước chạy sau hay chạy cùng lúc với
mình. Đấy kiểu thế.
Đây cái khái niệm axit này đúng không?
Mọi tron khi kết thúc đều đưa dữ liệu
của một trạng thái hợp lệ
từ một trạng thái hợp lệ sang một trái
hợp khác. Hồi trước là công ty tôi bị
đúng cái tình trạng này. Nghĩa là trong
một khoảng một khoảng khác một khoảng
khắc thôi nhá. Nhất định là dữ liệu
trong trường hợp đấy nó đang không hợp
lệ, đang không đúng lắm. Ông ông cứ hình
dung có một kiểu dạng như là kiểu bên
tôi muốn phản hồi về nhanh cho khách
hàng ấy nên là thanh toán đơn xong đơn
vẫn thực ra vẫn chưa tính là đã thanh
toán. Đấy kiểu một khoảnh khắc thế thôi.
Ông ông ông hiểu ý tôi không? Đấy
đấy thì rõ ràng là nó cũng có thể vi
phạm quy tắc về cái tính nhất quán.
Nghĩa là nghĩa là kiểu dữ liệu thì hiển
thị ra một kiểu vẫn báo cho khách hàng
là đã thanh toán thành công nhưng mà
thực ra là mình vẫn đang đợi web hook
đang đợi tiền bắn về các thứ các thứ để
xác nhận hối trước thực ra là không phải
mỗi bên tôi đâu. Cái cái này tôi biết
được có nhiều bên bị thế này xong rồi
còn có nhiều nhiều ông tricker à hồi
chưa hacker hoặ thậm chí là có cái vụ
nổi tiếng cái phim a Catch Me If You can
mà thực ra cũng lợi dụng cái kiểu kiểu
na ná kiểu như này này tức là để xác
thực được một cái giao dịch thì rõ ràng
phải qua nhiều bước ấy đôi khi là nó cứ
báo trước cho mình là thành công xong
rồi mình lợi dụng cái lúc đấy là mình
làm nhiều thứ xong lúc mà nó mà kiểu va
đết được cái cái giao dịch cái thất bại
rồi thì mình đã làm được nhiều cái rồi
thì kiểu thế đấy. Bởi vì rõ ràng là tại
sao đầu tiên là có ông thắc mắc à tại
sao lại làm thế? Mình phải vai đết chắc
chắn đã thì mình báo khách hàng nhưng mà
làm thế đôi khi nó rất là lâu. Mình
không làm thế là nó sẽ bị tụt khái niệm
trong bọn tôi làm về mạng bán hàng dịch
vụ này sẽ CR đúng không? Conversion rate
tức là cái hiệu suất quy đổi nó sẽ bị
giảm. Nghĩa là khách nó sẽ đi. Khách mà
kiểu cảm thấy là kiểu
đây đây kiểu một đơn hàng các thứ lại đề
cập luôn này. Nghĩa nói chung là liên
quan tiền n rất là nhạy cảm. Đó là khách
thấy thanh toán rồi là khách sẽ như nào
đấy các thứ. khách muốn có kết quả luôn
thay vì phải thông báo là bạn đợi tí
tiền tội về túi tôi đã thì nó cũng nói
chung là tùy mình cần khách mà
chỉ có ngân hàng hay hệ thống lớn là
theo kiểu là nó sợ bài toán rủi ro nó sợ
là kiểu bây giờ có nhiều thằng cùng bị
thế là tao sẽ bị nếu mà có vấn đề xảy ra
tao bị đền bù nhiều quá nên là tao phải
chắc chắn về nghiệp vụ đấy mày có thể
đợi cũng được nhưng tao không đợi được
kiểu thế Còn mình làm về trang thương
mại điện tử thì rõ ràng là mình cần
khách. Khách có khách nó bấm vào của
mình đôi khi bấm nhầm ấy, kiểu hiển địa
quảng cáo nó bấm nhầm vào ấy nên là mình
sẽ phải làm mọi thứ níu chân khách và
vòi được tiền của khách nên sẽ không có
chuyện mà mình kiểu mình lại bắt khách
phải đợi. Khách mà đợi thì ví dụ nó đã
bấm nhầm vào nó ngồi xem lướt qua một tí
để xem có cái gì thôi nó thoát đúng
không? bấm nó còn phải bắt nó đợi 3 4
giây để mà làm một cái thao tác nữa thì
nó đi ngay đúng không ạ?
Đúng rồi. Giống như bạn kia nói là nên
có sự đánh đổi chết off đúng không? Cái
này à cái này liên quan tí nó không phải
quyết định của anh em mình là dep mà
quyết định của thường là product owner
là người kiểu chịu rủi ro và quản lý về
chất lượng của cái sản phẩm dự án thì
người ta sẽ biết được cái nào nên đánh
đổi đúng không ạ?
Nhưng là tôi chỉ nói qua thế cho anh em
nào chưa động đến mảng ví dụ ý nhất là
giống như tôi vừa nói là mảng kim mại đi
tử hay các thứ thì anh em sẽ biết được
là kiểu cái gì cũng có hai mặt đúng
không ạ.
Trong bối cảnh đa luồng và tron
thì thường được hiểu là tính nhất quán
của trạng thái khi nhiều trùng truy cập.
Đúng rồi.
Đang bị sửa dở ra.
Nhiều người nhầm lẫn hai khái niệm và
sai lầm nghiêm trọng.
Ủa còn phân tán nữa.
Ở bên công ty tôi là cũng đa quốc gia,
cũng làm ở đ
server cũng đang quốc gia nên là thành
ra là khi mà khi mà đồng bộ dữ liệu về
từ
kiểu các khu vực về một nơi thống nhất
là gọi database master đúng không? thì
nó cũng liên quan đến vụ mấy cái vụ phân
tán này. Xong rồi xử lý xử lý phân tán
xử lý bốc một bộ nó cũng lằng nhắng phết
sẽ mang nghĩa là hẹp và đau đầu hơn. Mọi
nốt trong hệ thống khi đọc cùng một dữ
liệu tại cùng một thời điểm sẽ nhận được
cùng một giá trị. Đấy đấy đấy tôi đang
định nói này nghĩa là gì chỉ rõ ràng là
ở trên master chưa đồng bộ cái đơn đấy
về theo kiểu ví dụ là đơn đấy đã thanh
toán ở khu vực đấy rồi nhá nên chưa kịp
đồng bộ về đã thanh toán ở master thì rõ
ràng khi đọc
dữ liệu ở hai nơi khác nhau rõ ràng nó
sẽ trả về giá trị khác nhau đấy
thì chấp nhận sai lệch tạm thờ miễn là
cuối cùng sẽ đồng bộ lại. À đây đây cái
eventually này tôi nhớ là hôm trước tôi
có chia sẻ cái video TikTok gần đây lướt
TikTok nhiều nhưng mà may trên đây cũng
nhiều cái bổ ích. Đấy, tôi cũng nói về
khái niệm về à tôi có chia sẻ cái video
đấy ở trên kênh trên kênh Discord rồi
mấy ông thực ra tôi không thấy mấy ông
tương tác và mấy kênh đấy bao giờ nhưng
tôi vẫn thích chia sẻ
thì trên đấy ừ chắc là tôi không
tôi sẽ thỉnh thoảng tôi sẽ tải cái video
đấy nếu tải được rồi đăng lên a fanpage
cũng được để mấy ông có thể xem không
phải mỗi xem trên server Discord vì
nhiều người đúng là tôi thấy không để ý
disc lắm.
phải dính phải bài của tôi thôi
khả năng chịu lỗi.
sang hẳn kia. Thôi học tiếp nhá. Tring
builder nhưng có method. Method này là
method này là đồng bộ đúng không nhỉ?
À không, cái này không phải đồng bộ. Cái
này là
hôm nay học phần nào thế anh ơi? Hôm nay
sang ngày thứ ba em ạ. Tuy là ghi là
ngày hai nhưng thực ra là anh học trước
một buổi rồi. Hôm nay ngày 3 tí anh sẽ
đẩy mấy cái bài này lên để em xem trong
cái sườn nhá.
chỉ
thực thi một đoạn cốt hợp
cựng chế
này nó lại đang hơi lý thuyết quá để tôi
đọc xong rồi tôi thử thử. Thường là đôi
khi không biết là não ông mấy ông hoạt
động xử lý thế nào. Hưng não tôi thì sẽ
xử lý được kiểu khi đọc một cái gì đó
phức tạp. Cái này nó n nào giống như là
hồi à tôi học về triết học map Lenin hay
các thứ ấy kiểu bạn tôi thì tôi vẫn nhớ
như in hồi đấy. Có thể câu chuyện này
tôi từng kể rồi nhưng tôi cứ kể lại nhá.
là bạn tôi thời đấy bạn tôi đầu tiên là
bạn đấy định nhờ tôi giúp kiểu kiểm tra
miệng nhưng kiểm tra kiểu học vẹt thôi
vì bạn đấy kiểu bảo là mấy kiến thức này
khô khan và khó ấy đấy xong tôi bảo là
mấy cái này dễ học mà xong kiểu bạn ấy
kiểu vãi chưởng mày học được chết ma
xong rồi kiểu học được kiểu các thứ này
á xong rồi tôi đọc một lượt xong rồi tôi
giải thích cho nó nhưng bằng mấy cái
kiểu ví dụ công cụ sản xuất thì thì nó
là thực ra là mấy cái quốc xong mấy cái
kiểu nói chung là kiểu cái hình dung mấy
cái ví dụ đơn giản ấy. Đấy đại khái là
tôi đọc một cái phức tạp rồi tôi sẽ cố
biến nó thành cái đơn giản để tôi nhớ là
tôi dễ hình hiểu hơn. Đấy xong rồi tôi
giảng được cho nó. Đấy, xong rồi tôi
giảng xong xong rồi tầm hai tiếng thôi.
Rồi ngày hôm sau nó đi thi nó được 8
điểm xong nó về nó khỏ nó bảo là mày
nhất định về sau phải làm thầy giáo vì
mày có thể giảm một cái thứ rất là phức
tạp thể dễ hiểu được như thế. Đấy, đấy
một trong những cái rất là lớn làm tôi
về sau muốn đi dậy.
Thì cũng kiểu thế. Tôi nghĩ là mấy cái
này có thể bây giờ thực ra tôi nếu mà
tôi lười hơn thì tôi có thể dùng AI để
mà
bắt nó kiểu đơn giản hóa mấy cái này
cũng được.
Nghĩa là ông không cần phải học một cái
gì đó quá cứng ngắc quá cứng nhắc. Ông
chỉ cần hiểu bản chất của nó đúng không?
Nghĩa là một cái từ này giả sử ông không
biết được mà cái từ nàyểu không biết
được từ tiếng Anh dịch từ tiếng Việt
cũng được không sao miễn là mình làm mọi
thứ theo bản chất mà bởi vì rõ ràng là
vừa nãy ông thấy là tôi vừa gọi sai
chính tả cũng được tôi gõ tiếng Việt
cũng được thằng anh nó vẫn hiểu và nó
vẫn tạo ra code ở cho mình mà đúng không
quan trọng là mình hiểu bản chất và mình
biết được cơ chế hoạt động mọi thứ để
mình làm kiểu mục mục tiêu thì mình vẫn
là
tôi vẫn nói lại cái cốt lõi nhá mục tiêu
vẫn là mình là lập lập trình viên. Mình
không phải là người viết code. Mình lập
trình viên tức là mình sẽ là người làm
mọi thứ để mà giao tiếp về máy tính để
máy tính phục vụ cho mình. Đấy. Đấy. Cốt
lõi theo như tôi hiểu lập trình viên là
nên thế. Tức là mình có thể nói chuyện
giao tiếp như này mà máy tính hiểu, máy
tính làm được thì quá tuyệt vời luôn.
Đấy. Nhưng mà bây giờ máy tính chưa thế.
Bây giờ thì mình vẫn phải nói chuyện với
nó thông qua ngôn ngữ lập trình. Nhưng
mà bây giờ còn có hay là mình không nói
chuyện với nó theo cờ trực tiếp và ngôn
ngữ lập trình nữa. Mình nói với con AI,
con AI sẽ biến nó thành ngôn ngữ lập
trình để mà máy tính làm cho mình đúng
không ạ? Đấy
nhưng là nó vẫn chung quy lại vẫn là
mình lập trình viên mình là người kiểu
là chủ của nó. Mình phải kiểm soát được
nó và mình hiểu được nó làm được những
gì ra lệnh được cho nó. Còn ông nào mà
bị phụ thuộc, ông nào bị kiểu bó hẹp là
mình phải
theo phải kiểu giỏi ngôn ngữ này hay là
phải như nào như nào đấy thì rõ ràng là
nó đang hơi bó hẹp cái khả năng của mình
mà đúng không ạ?
loại lock đúng không?
Mỗi object đều có một ổ khóa ngầm.
khó hiểu dần rồi. Không sao, để tôi thử
bảo thừ đơn giản hóa kèm ví dụ
giải thích cho tôi được không?
Nó giải thích phức tạp như này bởi vì nó
nghĩ là trình độ mình đã đủ cao rồi và
nó nghĩ mình thông minh. Cứ thế đi. Đấy.
Thuật ngữ thừa đi thẳng vào bản chất.
Đúng rồi. Bởi vì nó nãy giờ nó dùng rất
nhiều thuật ngữ luôn. Tôi thấy là bắt
đầu hơi bị lạm dụng thuật ngữ.
là dễ dễ hơn cho các ông các ông và tôi
cùng nhìn thấy số tiên là 100 cộng thêm
10 dự định là ghi 110 cộng thêm 20 dự
định ghi là 120.
>> Tôi nhớ cái bình luận của gần đây đúng
gần đây có cái nổi trên TikTok và tôi
xem nhiều cái video kiểu thế người thông
minh như bạn sẽ nghĩ ra cách thứ làm các
thứ thứ buồn cười xong rồi kiểu toàn mấy
ông bình luận kèm ảnh tôi á đ cười được.
kết quả
có thể là 110 hoặc 120 nhưng không bao
giờ là 130. Đó là đấy, giống như tôi nói
nếu mà giả sử mà update đương nhiên là
cái lỗi SQL này có một cách sửa đó là
chỉ là cộng thêm vào chứ nó không kiểu
kiểu
nhưng mà đối với SQL như thế. Còn với
trong cái kiểu class xong rồi còn đa
luồng như này và dùng cái kiểu dạng như
này này.
Kiểu dạng ghi vào cái một cái gọi là một
cái địa chỉ nào đó. Đây địa chỉ bụ nhớ
mà đúng không? Đấy một cái achill nào đó
thì đôi khi là nó sẽ nó có thể tăng các
thứ các thử. Để xem nào.
được cầm bút ghi vào sổ người khác phải
chờ.
Ghi xong đặt bút xuống. Uây giải thích
kiểu kiểu dễ hình dung đúng không?
Ví dụ tối giản như sau. Chỉ cần đọc
không cần nhớ cúi pháp. Ok. Nghĩa ở đây
là khi chạy không được cái nào chạy trên
cùng method à khai báo kiểu như này
nghĩa là chỉ có thằng này duy nhất là
thằng được gọi đến cái hàm này thôi đúng
không? Đấy thằng này thằng sau gọi đến
thì nó sẽ phải đợi thằng này chạy xong
thì mới gọi được đúng không?
Nếu bỏ đi là sẽ kiểu
sẽ
tùy được may rồi. À đấy nói hay hay nói
câu nói hay lúc đúng lúc sai tùy may
rồi. Không biết là thằng này có kiểu lấy
giọng văn của tôi không nói chuyện nó
nhiều có khi giọng văn nào giống mình
đúng không?
anh có một tài khoản ngân hàng đấy. Ừ.
Bây giờ còn liên hoàn trừ tiền là còn
nhạy cảm hơn đúng không? Đấy số tiền
dư không âm vô lý do race condition đấy
nghĩa là nó là liên quan đến kiểm tra
điều kiện đúng không? Không được phép
âm.
Nếu không hai lệnh rút cùng nghĩ rằng
mình còn tiền đủ và trừ trồng lên nhau.
Đấy mỗi lần chỉ một tho. Uây ui ví dụ
này hay dễ hiểu kinh khủng luôn. Ví dụ
này được
hay thật.
đấy.
à
gọi như nào nhỉ? mấy cái bài về so sánh
hiệu năng các thứ các thứ thì chắc là
tôi mình chưa cần biết lắm ấy vì mình đã
làm dự án lớn để mình biết được lắm đâu.
Hơi khó để mà nói về cái này.
đâu xem nào. String là chuỗi cố định ít
thay đổi. Cái này dùng nhiều nhất nối
chuỗi, xử lý chuỗi phức tạp. Single
thread. Còn cái này chỉ dùng khi mà liên
quan đến kiểu
cái kia là parallel hay consistent đúng
không? Nó tiếng nó cái gì nhỉ?
Consistent à?
Đúng rồi. Consistency
đấy.
Đồng thời
hiếm dùng legacy code hiếm dùng cơ. Xem
ạ. Đấy.
Tránh nối chuỗi
trong
lúc.
Concruency. Ok. Ok. Concruency.
Ok. Uầy. Hôm nay tuy là nó rất nhiều
nhưng thực ra là mình đã xong buổi pa
rồi đấy.
[tiếng cười]
Thực ra là mình nói không phải mỗi học
nữa. Mình còn kiểu đây trao đổi các thứ
các thứ gọi là gì nhỉ? Ờ trao đổi chiêu
thức. Đấy.
Mỗi ngày thực ra tôi bảo chỉ nên học ít
này thôi bởi vì ngày hôm sau còn phải ôn
lại nhá. Đấy, hôm nay tôi còn ôn cả buổi
một buổi hai rồi. Ngày hôm sau nữa tôi
lại ngồi ôn lại tiếp có giờ thứ mỗi ngày
chỉ ít ít ít thôi đúng không ạ? Ông nào
bây giờ mới vào thì à tôi xem lại nhá.
Đấy, có ông nào còn à hỏi hay thắc mắc
gì thêm không ạ?
mà mình sẽ cứ kiểu có chủ đề để mình nói
kiểu thêm những cái kiểu liên quan nữa.
Tôi cảm thấy thật ra nó vẫn đâu chỉ dừng
lại ở mỗi hôm nay học mỗi chuỗi đâu đúng
không? Hôm nay thực ra tôi thấy nó nhiều
nhất lại liên quan về việc đa luồng cơ
về cái các thứ kiểu kia cơ đúng không?
Chuỗi chỉ là một phần thôi đúng không?
Đấy và thậm chí là mấy cái này về sau
hôm nay có đề cập thấy xong rồi những
cái bài những cái bài sau này ấ có nhắc
đến đa luồng hay các thứ thứ ấy mình
kiểu
não mình tôi nhớ có một cái rất là hay
đó là có thể là mình thấy khó ngay tại
thời điểm hiện tại nhưng mà tuy là mình
không được phép nói với nó là mình bỏ
cuộc ví dụ nhá ví dụ nhá tôi nhớ hồi
trước có một cái ví dụ tôi đọc được thôi
Nhưng mà tính của tôi là tôi hôm trước
tôi có tra thì tôi theo ch nghĩa. Hồi
trước tôi tưởng duy tâm như không đúng.
Tôi theo duy trí chị ạ. Mình theo cái
niềm tin của mình là đôi khi chính vì
niềm tin đấy. Kiểu
cái này tôi nói và mấy ông phải nghe.
Hôm trước tôi thử nói bạn gái bạn gái
không nghe nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là bây giờ
tôi nói mấy ông phải nghe thôi. Bình
thường bây giờ tôi thử hỏi lại mấy ông
về lý thuyết về duy vật và duy tâm đúng
không ạ?
À tôi tôi vẫn nói là tôi nói theo cái lý
thuyết mà tôi biết thôi nhá. Có thể
không đúng mấy ông lại bảo lại sửa lại
tôi nhá. Thì
thì à nhiều người bảo là theo chủ nghĩa
duy vật chẳng hạn bởi vì người ta coi
vật chất là quyết định ý thức đúng
không? Nghĩa là kiểu phải có vật chất
trước thì mình mới có kiểu ý thức hay là
mới có kiểu gì đó đúng không? Đấy và từ
cái đấy kết luận ra cái duy trí tức là
là duy trí tức là mình phải có lý trí và
lý trí đấy mình sẽ quyết định cái
những cái khác. Đấy còn bình thường theo
di tâm là mình sẽ có ý thức và mình sẽ
chuyển hóa nó thành vật chất.
Câu đấy không biết đúng hay không nhưng
lại khái cái ý thức ở đây tôi nhớ về cái
di tâm ấy nó lại theo kiểu sống theo
kiểu dạng như là
ông không cần vật chất ông kiểu dạng là
ông có thể tự mình tịnh được rồi kiểu
thế còn duy trí thì nó sẽ không phải như
thế duy trí theo kiểu là dùng lý trí để
mà quyết định ra nhiều cá thì
đợi tí tại sao à thì ý tôi thế nghĩa là
tôi tin vào một cái gì dần dần nó sẽ
nó sẽ thành đúng ấy kiểu thế.
Và tại sao tự nhiên tôi đề cập cái đấy?
Vì vừa nãy có nói về vụ là học cái này
lúc đầu khó nhưng mà tôi từng nghe cái
nó là lúc đầu có ai đó hỏi ông một câu,
ông có thể chưa biết đáp án ngay nhưng
ông không ông không bỏ cuộc nghĩ đến nó.
Đôi khi là ông không cần nghĩ nha. Nhưng
não ông kiểu nó vẫn tự động nghĩ, nó
kiểu chạy kiểu chạy ngầm ấy. Đấy, nó vẫn
sẽ chạy ngầm ở đằng sau. Nếu mà ông
nếu mà ông kiểu dạng là à
kiểu dạng ông không ngừng nghĩ thôi, tôi
chẳng biết được diễn ra câu đấy như này.
Đại khái là ông không bỏ cuộc, nghĩ vậy
bình thường bỏ cuộc là như nào? Ví dụ
giả sử không câu đấy khó quá tao không
làm được thì tự nhiên là ông giống như
ông chặn kiểu ông chạy lệnh chặn luôn
không cho não nghĩ nữa nhưng ông sẽ bảo
là để tôi sẽ nghĩ các thứ thứ
và đúng là não ông sẽ tự động nghĩ ngầm
cái đấy thật và về sau khi mà người ta
nhắc lại câu đấy đôi khi ông có luôn câu
trả lời đấy kiểu kiểu như thế ví dụ là
hồi đấy đã từng có nhà khoa học thử thí
nghiệm cái vụ đấy là thử hỏi bạn một
phép toán kiểu ví dụ là mấy trăm cộng
mấy trăm bao nhiêu ấy nhưng mà thay vì
để người ta trả lời ngay người ta sẽ
kiểu đánh chống lảng để người kia làm
những cái việc khác và hỏi những câu
khác người kia chưa kịp chưa kịp trả lời
và chưa kịp tính nhá chưa kịp tính nhẩm
trong đầu cái đấy phải tính nhầm cái
không thể phát ra ngay đấy người ta muốn
cho một cái bài toán mà không thể phát
ra ngay được không thể tính nhẩm nhanh
được ấy nhưng người ta vẫn có tính nhẩm
trong đầu và khi mà cái nhà thính nghiệm
đấy là thử hỏi lại ông đấy cái câu hỏi
ban đầu tính kia ông ấy bật luôn luôn
được ra kết quả. Tức là bản chất là não
mình có chạy đa luồng và chạy ngầm để xử
lý cái thông tin kia. Đấy thì tương tự
giống như là những cái lần đầu mình học
mình có thể thấy khó như này nhưng mà
mình không bỏ cuộc. Dần dần về sau mình
có nhắc lại thì mình lại thấy nó sẽ dễ
hơn bởi vì não mình bản chất là mình đã
đã có động đậy cho cái điều đấy rồi. Đấy
cái này theo khoa học nhá.
Đâu nay học Java mới có mấy khái niệm
này nhỉ? Đúng rồi, đúng rồi. Đấy, thế
nên là tôi mới cảm thấy là Java hay mà
kiểu mình sẽ biết rồi thêm nhiều cái mới
và ừ và mình sẽ mình sẽ kiểu thắc mắc là
tại sao mọi người dùng Java. Đấy, có
những cái dự án mà chỉ dùng Java thôi
không dùng PP. Đấy, tại sao như thế?
Không phải bởi vì là nó ngại thay đổi
đâu. Đấy, thậm chí là tôi vẫn nhớ là cái
gần đây nhất thôi. Đó là cái à bên giao
hào tiết kiệm à hồi trước giao h tiết
kiệm dùng PP Larel nhá. Còn bây giờ
chuyển qua Go và Java thì phải. Đấy. Tại
sao lại chuyển qua như thế? Hồi trước
chỉ thuần PP cơ mà. Đấy thì mấy ông sẽ
hình dung được là có lý do của nó đúng
không?
multiad. Bây giờ xem viết chủ đề string
thì anh em back and spam nội dung này
của gia sớm thì em làm tốt phép. Đúng
đúng đúng nghĩa là đấy kiểu mình học
thầy khai sảng nhưng mà tôi bảo rồi may
mà tôi học cái này sau lúc mà tôi đã
biết tôi cảm thấy là tôi hơi đi dùng t
đi sau đúng hơn là đi ngược
hơi đi sau mọi người kiểu như thế nghĩa
là
rõ ràng là bình thường là mọi người có
thể học những cái lý thuyết như này
trước hồi đại học đúng không tôi đã học
nghề trước đấy tôi làm thực hành trước
nhưng mà tôi lại cảm thấy tôi quen cái
đấy hơn. Tức hồi đầu mà tôi học tôi hồi
đấy tôi trở đại học mà tôi không biết là
tôi đội đại học và tôi học một cái này
xong có khi bây giờ tôi không làm được
lập trình viên chẳng hạn nó khó có thể
thế đấy
tôi học nghề trước và tương tự thế tôi
học môn PP nó dễ hơn Java này trước đấy
để bây giờ tôi cảm thấy tôi quay lại thì
tôi vẫn học được chứ bây giờ để mà tôi
nhảy thẳng luôn vào lý thuyết C X C+ C+
xong Java các thứ như này rồi đi làm
bằng Java nữa thì à
tôi lại nghĩ tôi khó cạnh tranh hơn vì
PP tính ra là học nhanh xong rồi đi làm
nhanh được đấy.
tu. Đúng đúng dùng từ thể tu rồi.
Tại sao bạn không học Go hay Rus mà lại
học Java?
Ờ
thì còn chưa tìm hiểu về go cả rus.
Nhưng mà nếu mà sau Java này có thể mình
sẽ sang Go bởi vì nhiều người bảo t PP
thì nên nhảy sang go nhưng mà mình học
Java ở code để mà biết về OP và những
cái kiểu xử lý mọi thứ những cái m PP
đang
dùng từ hạn chế nhá. có thể là có rồi
nhưng mà hạn chế vân vân này. Đấy và
mình và khi mà mình học này mình cố thể
học cái tư duy của một ông backend, một
ông về thiết kế thiết kế hệ thống này
các thứ thứ chứ không phải là mỗi mỗi
học ngôn ngữ. Đấy thực ra các bạn thấy
mình nói mình còn không code một dòng
nào mà mình chưa code một dòng nào Java
hay các thứ thứ này để mà bảo là mình
đang học cú pháp hay là đang học ngôn
ngữ. đúng không ạ? Mình chỉ dựa vào cái
này để biết được là
kiểu sự khác kiểu tư duy ý học cái tư
duy đúng không? Đấy thì rõ ràng là thậm
chí là giả sử về sau sang go thì mình
cũng sẽ học kiểu na nán như này nhưng mà
mình lại nghĩ mình hơi mình chưa tìm
hiểu nhá nhưng mình cứ nghĩ đó là học
Java này mà xong ổn nhá. Tôi tin là học
sang Go nó lại ngắn và dễ hơn cơ. Đấy
tôi nghĩ thế.
trúc dữ liệu. Ừ thuật toán thực ra tôi
cũng có đụng vào nhiều lắm đâu. À thế
nên là rất nhiều lúc mà hồi trước mấy
cái bài toán kiểu mà nó phức tạp một tí
tôi cũng nhiều xếp viết cách toán hay
các thứ thứ để nó hợp lý hơn.
Ờ nhưng mà còn à cấu trúc dữ liệu thì ý
không là cấu trúc dữ liệu và giải thuật
đúng không? Cái đấy tôi nhớ tôi học ba
lần nhưng mà tôi vẫn không chặng. Nghĩa
là tôi học cho lúc học phải thì hiểu ấy
nhưng mà không thể giải thích và cũng
như là rất khó ứng dụng. Thời mà tôi bây
giờ tôi làm có liên quan đến kiểu
database mọi thứ thứ ấ thì có thể có
đụng vào một tí nhưng mà đấy là mình
kiểu mình vẫn dựa theo kinh nghiệm mình
để mà mình à tự tự thiết kế database
thôi chứ không phải là
mình kiểu thành thục. Bởi vì tôi nhớ cái
đấy là một trong những cái khó và nó cái
quan trọng ấy đó là nó ít thực tiễn
không phủ nhận về độ thực tiễn nó rất là
tốt. Nhưng mà đang nói là ít thực tiễn ở
đây tức là sao? Nghĩa là ví dụ nói về
cái vụi chuẩn hóa đi. Thực ra database
bây giờ tôi đa số tôi biết nhá. Đấy
không làm theo chuẩn hóa mà nó chỉ chuẩn
hóa một cách tương đối thôi. Bởi vì mình
đôi khi là mình không muốn mình chấp
nhận rủi ro chấp nhận những cái bài toán
về cả vụ không nhất quán với dữ liệu này
này. Nghĩa là bảng bảng này chấp nhận
lưu thừa dữ liệu hơn để mà để mà đỡ phải
join, đỡ phải kiểu lấy thông tin từ bảng
khác vân vân. Đấy kiểu thế
nó đã sai chuẩn hóa rồi đấy. Nên là học
vẫn chỉ là lý thuyết thôi mà đúng không?
Vẫn phải theo thực tiễn
Thì về sau tôi học Go tôi tôi phải hứa
cái vụ học Java này cách đây 2 năm rồi.
Thì tôi không biết hứa vụ học Gâu là
cách đây bao sẽ là bao bao xa nữa.
nhiều. Ok
được.
không ngại. Tôi thật sự tôi không ngại
đâu. Nhưng mà quan trọng là đấy xem mấy
ông có đủ ngại đủ kiếp nhẫn này không
thôi. Hiện tại thì tôi thấy là tôi nhớ
thời đầu tôi livestream hồi học dạy về
chẳng hạn. Hôm đầu tiên là tận hơn tr
người tôi vẫn nhớ hơn tr người hôm kiểu
khai giảng ấy. Đấy về sau là chỉ có hơn
10 người. Hiện tại thì bên Java này cũng
sẽ thế.
thời đầu thì sẽ đông về sau là sẽ kéo nó
sẽ khác. Đấy
liệu trong bảng thì không phải ấy sẽ
khái niệm flash database ạ. Nghĩa là chỉ
nó sẽ kiểu mình chấp nhận là việc mình
lưu dư thừa để mình đỡ phải truy vấn
sang bảng khác. Đấy nhưng mà nó chính vì
như thế nó sẽ có thể sinh ra sai đúng
không? Nghĩa là giữ liệu bảng khác cập
nhật rồi bên này chưa cập nhật hay vân
vân. Thường mình lưu thêm cái đấy mình
thường hay lưu cột ID thôi. Code để mà
kiểu mình ánh xạ sang đất dễ. Và những
cái cột ID đấy phải ít khi thay đổi nữa.
Dòng thời gian Samsung J2 khó nói. Ừ lỗi
tôi. Tôi hồi trước tôi cũng là kiểm
duyệt bên đấy và tôi cũng
không thường xuyên duyệt bài. Tôi thường
hay kiểu thường xuyên duyệt bình luận
hơn. Nên này cũng lỗi tôi một phần là
không phải thường không phải ghét việc
duyệt bài mọi thứ đâu mà duyệt bài nhiều
lúc nó cũng hơi khó ấy kiểu xóa bài dễ
duyệt bài mấy ông mới khó bởi có nhiều
bài phải kiểm tra vân vân có nhiều bài
hồi trước là phần mềm là phải kiểm tra
virus nhá xong rồi lẫn cả là còn phải
xem ví dụ nhá tôi on vào cái giờ nó oái
ăn kiểu nửa đêm chẳng hạn thì tôi không
phải duyệt bài đấy bởi vì rõ ràng duyệt
bài đấy thì
làm bài không ai đọc thì nó cũng ảnh
hưởng đúng không ạ? Đấy, nghĩa là mình
phải on vào đúng giờ nữa để mà duyệt bài
và lắm cả. Nếu mà on đúng giờ đi ông chỉ
duyệt được một hay hai bài thôi. Bởi vì
ông chẳng lẽ ông duyệt chục bài vào lúc
đấy thì nó làm ảnh hưởng những bài khác
đúng không? Nó làm ông ông hiểu ý tôi
không? Chục bài thì bài sẽ bị flop, bài
sẽ bị trôi đúng không? Đấy lại chỉ duyệt
được một hai bài thôi. Đấy thành ra là
xóa là nhiều chữ duyệt thì ít. Và cách
dễ duyệt nhất thì đó đi duyệt bình luận,
duyệt kiểu để ý duyệt thành viên hay các
thứ. Duyệt dễ nhất thì duyệt lúc đấy.
Duyệt cái đấy rồi lúc nã nào cũng được.
Đấy thành hồi đấy tôi kiểm duyệt là
chuyên về duyệt những cái khác hơn là
duyệt bài đăng nên là bài đăng nó tần
suất trong bài đăng trong đấy là luôn
trong 400 500 bài. Không biết bây giờ
thế nào bây giờ có công cụ AI chắc đỡ
hơn.
đôi khi là người ta lấy tài liệu từ đâu
về chia sẻ kiểu rất là sợ rất là ghê ấ
nhưng mà không biết được nó có thực sự
đem lại giá trị không ý ví dụ người ta
chia sẻ tt
tra b tài liệu học tiếng anh không biết
là đã chôn về ở những đâu kiểu thế nghe
nghe hồi trước mình có thể rất là hay
nhưng mà tôi từng thấy kiểu cái bài đôi
khi đăng đi lại có nhiều bên và đôi khi
là nó dính bản quyền hoặc là đôi khi là
nó chỉ đơn giản nó nó hơi rác dữ liệu
thôi. Kiểu kiểu có ai là người duyệt
được đống đấy kiểu ngồi đọc hết đống đấy
để mà
để mà kiểu biết được là nó là thực sự là
tài liệu chất cho mấy ông đúng không?
Không ai cả không ai có thời gian để làm
gì cả. Đấy thế đôi khi không rất khó
duyệt mấy cái bài kiểu như thế.
Tôi nhớ là bài đấy phải để 2 năm.
Hình như bài vẫn chưa đồ duyệt hồ bị xóa
không biết đâu.
lại mọi thứ
bởi vì chúng ta học những cái
nó liên quan đến đô la liên quan tiền ấy
và nó không chặt chẽ [tiếng cười]
không sao. Trong PP nó khái niệm là biến
mà đúng không? Trong này làm gì có biến
biến tức là đây
kiểu biến động
Thấy nhiều chữ khó nhớ ác. Đấy do mà tôi
học cùng mấy ông để mà nó có tương tác
kiểu để mà nhớ một cái gì đó lâu ấy thực
ra ông phải tương tác rất nhiều với nó.
Còn nếu mà ông chỉ đọc
cùng lắm và thực hành nữa nhá thì ông sẽ
không nhớ nó rõ đâu. Đấy tôi nói chuyện
với mấy ông như này, mấy ông có thể nghĩ
là địt mẹ thằng này tập trung học gì
cả. Nhưng mà đúng hồi trên trường hồi
ngay từ hồi bé đến giờ là tôi không hề
tập trung học.
Tôi học vẫn rất tốt nhá. Bởi vì tôi
thì nói như nào cứ cho nói đa luồng đi.
Vừa học vừa ngồi nói chuyện với bạn bè
hoặc là đôi khi không nói chuyện bạn bè
thì giờ tay phát biểu hay làm mọi cách
để mà không chỉ ngồi cắm đầu vào kiểu
ngồi dán mắt vào đọc hay là cái gì đó nó
sẽ bị nhiều người bảo buồn ngủ hay mất
tập trung gì gì đó rất nhiều cái đúng
không? Đấy, mình sẽ phải làm nhiều thứ
nhưng nó không làm ảnh hưởng quá, không
làm mình mỗi phân tâm bị sao nhãm quá,
không làm mình bị các thứ quá
thì tôi cảm thấy nó lại là cái kiểu hằn
sâu trong cái trí ức của ông. Có rất
nhiều tương tác tại thời điểm đây nên là
nó sẽ dễ nó sẽ rất dễ nhớ.
Về sau mấy ông có thể kiểm tra miệng lại
tôi mấy cái này tôi nhớ nhá.
Tôi sợ tôi kiểm tra miệng mấy ông mấy
ông không nhớ. Thôi
[tiếng cười]
kể dễ tôi chấp mấy ông biết về cả Java
trước rồi nhá
làm một quả ca hút xong rồi mấy ông sẽ
ngồi cùng làm cùng tôi.
À thế như tôi ra đề thì chắc là hay là ừ
tôi về sau tôi không biết c hood bây giờ
nó có cái
import bằng reason không? Chắc là có.
Chắc có hỗ trợ còn không thích về xong
tự mình code một cái app đấy cũng được.
À nhưng mà retime thì cũng tốn không
biết được. Nhưng đại khái là ừ học Java
biết đâu về sau code cái app kiểu tương
tự thế. Thế ý tôi là về sau dùng AI để
mà tự tạo ra câu hỏi ngẫu nhiên để tôi
cũng không gọi là không a gì nhỉ ra lận
nha. Đấy xong rồi anh em mình cùng làm
máy trắc nghiệmấy.
vui đã
nảy ra rất nhiều cái ý tưởng các thứ các
thứ đấy. Mà tôi cứ mỗi lần như thế xong
tôi lại cảm thấy kiểu tăng năng lượng
ấy, kiểu phấn khích ý. Đấy, tính tôi rất
là dễ bị phấn khích vìểu. Cảm thấy ui nó
hay quá các thứ các thứ.
Thường kiến thức à?
Kiến thức thì cũng tuyệt đấy nhưng mà
thứ anh cần là
thôi tôi nghĩa thì xem TikTok quá thôi
cũng gần hai tiếng rồi thôi tôi nghĩ là
tôi sẽ tạm cho anh em ngừng ở đây tôi
cũng cứu cho cái cổ tôi. Hôm qua tôi nói
khản cả giọng và hôm nay sẽ
đang khản giọng rồi đây. Đấy
em, cảm ơn anh em đã lắng nghe ạ. Tạm
biệt ạ. Đúng rồi, sẽ có thể sẽ học một
ngày. Có gì tôi sẽ thông báo nếu có vấn
đề kiểu có cái gì phát sinh. X chào anh
em nhé.